Well,
good experience my day,
Joe Rogan podcast,
my name is Byrd crusher.
He's a mother fucking world traveler on
like any other and even if he stops
doing this travel channel Gig,
he will be more traveled than any of you
folks.
You've essentially,
you've traveled way more than the
average person ever will in their life
just in the last few years
if you just talk about this stuff I've
done on a daily basis.
We talked about this at one day you
called me and you said,
what are you doing?
I said,
I'm driving an old Russian motorcycle
through rice paddies and Vietnam.
And you were like,
kind of talk about that on stage.
Like,
yeah,
you do.
I'm annoying as fuck a party if anyone's
like,
oh,
we went zip lining.
I was like,
fuck fucking zip lining.
I did one 20 on flight lines outside of
Vegas,
almost broke my fucking knees.
And they're like,
Huh.
So I almost broke your knees,
your knees.
So these,
um,
these flight lines are basically a zip
lines on steroids.
They're massive cables and then massive
rigs and you have to control your body
in the wind so that you don't go over a
hundred miles an hour because it's
really hard to stop you.
However,
if the winds are bad,
they'll cancel them.
We were already up into the hike.
Six miles.
You take the hike all the way through
Ziploc flight line than hike.
You hike for six miles.
You're like all fucking day flight line,
a mile and a half and then hiked to the
next flight line than flight line two
miles.
They're long.
They're fucking gangster there in
Bootleg Canyon in Vegas.
Go outside and do them.
They're amazing.
How long is the ride?
The rides?
Probably a minute and a half minute,
ma'am.
You're flying.
You're fucking flying.
When a bug hits your face,
it hurts.
It hurts to get hit in the face,
but hidden fucking bugs by bugs.
A walk.
I'm going to use a goose.
I think about that constantly.
Large fucking angry bird having to Fabio
what?
Yeah.
Fuck.
You don't know if it was riding roller
coasters in New Jersey and a fucking
single hit him in the face and broke his
nose.
No,
just type in.
Just type in Fabio Goose fucking
rollercoaster.
God,
my father,
God's tired of seeing all of his
favorite romance novels were fucking
Fabio and the cover.
That's what it was.
Everyone Fabio used to pose for those
romance covers.
Romance books.
We're so fucking strange because they
were like men that didn't truly exist in
nature.
It's like,
I think that's probably where like
monitors came from,
the idea of a man.
It was like half worse.
That's mandatory,
right?
Yeah.
Where was the house fun be.
Oh,
you got crushed.
So.
Wow.
So yeah,
I think about getting hit by bugs and
fucking
I see it.
There's no actual video of the,
uh,
the goose hitting him in the face.
What are the do just as tired of not
getting attention.
So he just wailed on his own nose
consumption.
We all make a deal here.
This is a goose that hit my face smacked
of every fucking anyway.
In any of your.
Everyone was no romance novels would be
this long haired guy who was super
romantic.
It was essentially like a morph between
a man and a woman.
It was like a woman's desire for
Amanda's six,
one like beautiful,
handsome and blond man with this long
luxurious mane of hair and he was always
like holding her.
Like she was like,
she was just going limp and he was
holding her body weight and that's what
sold the book.
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
Because he did other authors.
He didn't just do one author and that
would sell the book.
Fabio would sell the fucking book and it
wasn't even a picture of it.
It was just a drawing is a drawing of
like a Fabio ass character.
I wonder if he would like Kim
Kardashians sued because some,
there was some character and some
commercial that looked like her.
So she sued,
you know,
like I,
I guess they contacted her and she
didn't want to do it.
Was that a why?
But it was that William shatner
commercial.
There was a William Shatner commercial
where Kim Kardashians comes rolling in
like a karate martial and has like
leathers on it.
Look,
I thought it was Kim Kardashian,
Kim Kardashian video game that she had
nothing to do with at first.
Uh,
and then she sued them and now she's
making shitloads of money off that game
that an app is a little different.
I mean,
this is a,
she sued last year for $20 million
because there was a woman in a,
in a,
in a commercial.
The chick's name is,
it's an old navy commercial.
The woman's name is Melissa Moe and
narrow.
And she sued because they looked like
his friends with Melissa.
Okay.
Well she's that musician girl.
Right?
I know there's probably a lot of girls
named Melissa.
I think that's fair.
I don't know.
Why don't you google it?
You got it.
It was actually a deck loaded.
Melissa Mayer narrows.
Including a senator's assistant.
Yeah.
There's probably quite a few of those
girls with that name.
Do you know that girl?
She does look like Kim Kardashians.
Yeah,
a little bit.
Yeah.
I mean,
she looks like her a little bit,
but how,
I mean,
what.
No girls with dark hair or allowed to be
on TV anymore.
Is that what's going on?
We have to pretend that every girl with
dark hair is pretending to be you.
How fucking egotistical.
He's stealing her essence though.
But that's insane.
Look,
if someone comes along and creates like
a Bert Kreischer,
wild,
crazy guy with a beard who drinks and
gets.
You can't see that guy.
That's like,
that's an archetype that's existed
before the,
the how,
you know,
the simple minded gal who was
materialists who just wants to take
photographs.
That's not a,
this isn't a new thing.
You know?
She is actually on a desk squad podcast.
I had that same girl.
You got sued?
Yeah.
As long ago.
Was this,
this was a three.
19,
2011 with me and Nestor and Melissa Mall
there.
Oh,
so it was before she got sued because
she got sued.
It says here in August of 2012 was crazy
shit.
Yeah,
but it was like what I thought of doing
a.
I thought of a.
We were doing a episode for triplepundit
Ella and I was thinking about getting
um,
look alikes,
like composite person,
like,
like 30 of them and have them at a
party.
So I was like,
hey,
you guys wanting to meet celebrities.
This is Michael Jackson.
And they'd be like,
they would,
I mean like they're from,
they're from Indiana.
They wouldn't know for like the first
five minutes they'd meet like,
like we would start soft,
this is Katie Bell.
And they'd be like,
Whoa,
you know what you do do to get them
drunk first.
Celebrities all come out of a room
together was like,
what if he got Hitler really loaded it
with ridiculous.
You have to give him an acid.
This is Jimmy Hendrix.
So anyway,
so he got hit in the nose by doc and
fucked him up.
So you,
you were on these things and you're
actually worried about getting hit.
Oh Yo.
Definitely 100% worried about Ken does
no precautions,
right?
You don't wear.
I do wear a helmet or anything.
You got your all,
you're in like a big five point harness
and then you'd just go fly in.
He's pushing a rock your body like
you're supposed to literally go out like
this and for sometimes they'll put a
parachute behind you to slow you down.
Lord,
the weather changed on us and I was
getting nervous because it's lightening
and you're on these big steel platforms
in Vegas,
in the middle of the desert.
And I was like,
I was like,
fuck it.
I'm going,
I'm going right now.
And they're like,
well maybe we should.
I was like,
fuck it.
And I was already locked in and the guy
sent me of the winds picked up behind
me.
So they started pushing me and I came in
hot as fuck.
I mean,
you have like these big stoppers that
are supposed to stop you.
I blew through all of them,
blew through the emergency one and went
up into the rigging.
I just remembered someone at the very
beginning of the day say,
renting passingly when in doubt legs
out.
And so like when in doubt,
throw your legs out,
looks pretty legs.
And I just,
that's what I thought to myself.
I spread my fucking legs and I want to
put the rigging rack my balls,
like fucking hit my tank.
I thought I broke my Cox's come out and
then I shoot like here's the worst part
is I shoot back because you went into
the rigging.
I shot back 150 feet into the fucking
out into the valley.
And I was like,
fucking stuck there.
And the guy had to come out and I'm
fucking,
oh Jesus.
So I come in and the guy's like,
he's like,
man,
you have no fucking idea how lucky you
are that you just had your legs up and
you have no fucking idea.
I was like,
really?
He's like,
yeah,
you would've broken if I'd had them
together.
I would've gone up.
My legs would have hit the rigging
instead of me like straddling it and uh,
and I would have fucking shattered my
legs easily.
Must have worried that it's going to
shatter your hip.
The way you hit it.
It sounds like that's brutal.
I,
nothing happened to me.
And I know that sounds crazy,
but nothing happened to me,
but you just go and went up like this
instead of like going on in,
breaking my legs like this and then pop
down and then shut all the way back.
Okay.
So what it is is like as you're going
down,
if your legs were in the way,
it'd be too much before the solid
rigging hits the.
If your legs with your legs would've,
you would've hit the rigging.
But before the whole system does.
Yeah.
But instead it sounds ridiculous.
It's uh,
there's,
you know,
I look to the level of chance and all
these things I do,
like,
it's the simplest ones where you get
hurt.
The only times I've been hurt was on a
blog and Texas.
It's like a big inflatable kind of
mattress where they have filled with air
and you lay on the end and then some guy
jumps off a 30 foot dock and when he
lands,
it's Einstein's theory of relativity.
Every action there is an opposite and
equal reaction.
And you shoot up equally as high as he
went versus his weight.
So if he's more than you,
do you compensate for that and you go up
in the air and you go into the water?
Fuck,
it's fucking insane.
But uh,
I didn't,
I felt myself flipping and I'm not like
a natural gymnast so I didn't want to
flip.
So I started kicking my legs so I kicked
him as hard as I could and I kicked both
my hamstrings out.
Oh my God.
Fucking the most painful thing I've ever
found.
Both of them,
both of my hamstrings out.
Just don't know in the sense that,
uh,
I just didn't walk for like three weeks.
You couldn't walk for three good no walk
for three weeks.
They,
I couldn't.
I was in the water and I was literally
holding my legs and it's a kids camp.
Always kids around me and I'm just
holding my legs,
like in massive pain.
And they're like,
we need you to go again.
I go,
I can't go again.
And like,
they,
it doesn't look dangerous.
Do you need to go a couple of times with
these things to make sure that they've
got the shot and they can get at
different angles.
So,
uh,
I was like,
I can't go.
And they were like,
are you fucking serious?
And they had to carry me to the firmer
at this Christian youth camp.
I go into my bag,
take a handful of tenants because I
mean,
it's,
I've never felt that pain in my life.
Just have travel.
I traveled with nausea medicine and
painkillers always because you never
know if you get hurt and if you get hurt
in the middle of the outback in the
middle of the Sahara,
you like,
if you get fucking.
So you get attacked by a fucking line
and you're not going to die.
But you have a fucking six hour bumpy
car ride in.
I want painkillers and I'm prepared.
Painkiller addiction.
No,
I don't know.
You know what?
Telling us about no painkiller addiction
whatsoever.
They scare me.
However,
when you are hurt,
like when I believe that the hamstrings,
I grabbed two viking in pop them and I
was manageable until they got me to the
hospital.
But,
but I just sit and wait.
They had to fucking wait forever.
They had a prayer circle around me.
Prayer circle what kind of prayers?
Fucking Jesus being God's counsel
counselor played along with him.
Of course he did write quotes,
learning realm because it's like,
look,
this looks like the guy from 30 rock
that like the white blonde haired,
Nerdy Guy,
right?
He like all these kids around my,
around my bed.
And he goes,
are you all thinking what I'm thinking?
They were like,
yeah.
And he goes,
Bert,
do you mind if we bury on you?
And I said,
uh,
I was fucking out of it if I got into
and hell,
I'm presuming.
And I was like,
fuck,
bring it.
So they,
they,
uh,
fuck,
bring it up.
I probably said sure,
I'd love that Carson.
So they form a circle so awkward because
I'm out of it and I like,
instead of the kids hands on my
shoulders.
But I wanted to touch him,
so I grabbed his inner like thigh and
I'm holding the counselors hand and they
preyed on me,
but then they preyed on me and I prayed
with them and it was awesome.
Dude.
Yeah.
I always have emergency like,
well these days when I've been traveling
abroad,
I always bring a little baby bottles of
Jack Daniel's with me on my,
on the flights because a lot of these
airlines don't serve alcohol.
Do you go to places where alcohol is
illegal in some Muslim countries where
alcohol is illegal,
right?
Yeah.
It was just in Zanzibar.
We can get alcohol and I didn't get much
alcohol.
Most Muslim countries,
uh,
even um,
even Dubai,
you can get it.
Yeah.
Get it in bars,
in bars it's like,
because they want to accommodate
westerners and especially Europeans.
Europeans love to drink and they want to
be a tourist location.
That's the,
that's the big killers.
A lot of these large Muslim investors
are going into Muslim countries like
Zanzibar and buying up hotels,
but they're not comfortable with alcohol
and new and like bathing suits and some
of the most beautiful hotels in all of
East Africa are just Muslim owned and
they,
they're vacant,
they're dead.
There's nothing but lizards.
Wow.
Because nobody wants to go into play.
Well,
that's good.
No market dictates your ideas are
stupid.
Chicks wear bikinis.
How dare you said no haters.
They had a sports bar and the one we
were in and I said,
I'll take a heineken and the manager
came up to me so you know,
we're a Muslim hotel,
we don't serve alcohol.
And I was like,
if it's a sports bar,
you changed the name of it.
Just don't say it.
The sport is.
I thought I read sports bar.
What did they say to that?
She goes,
uh,
she looks at me and goes,
what do you want?
And I said,
I want like appearance goes for the,
for the night.
I said,
I want to 12 pack.
She goes,
me,
me in your room,
and 10 came.
Nobody came back to my room,
sec,
don't take them out of your room so she
can smell that.
He had bought the.
He bought the hotel within,
I would say within weeks of what?
Of US booking the entire trip and so
they still had a stock of alcohol,
so it was just changing over.
Was just changing over to a Muslim
hotel.
He took the chance though,
Dude.
I've had known that.
I would've never fucking say they're not
in a million.
Fuck.
No,
I mean it was empty.
It was like having the place to yourself
is really because no one was at.
No one would go there and if they are
there and they're Muslim,
they're not in the pool.
So the pool to myself,
it was crazy.
When I was in Japan,
they made me cover up my tattoos.
Japan's fucking weird like that.
Right.
Did you go to any of the big subways in
Japan or any of the big train stations?
Fucking silent.
It will talk to each other.
Like,
I have a video on my phone.
It's probably my computer of me sitting
at the.
At what is their times square in Tokyo
at rush hour at like 8:00
AM in the morning,
6:00
AM,
7:00
AM in the morning,
not a fucking word.
You don't hear a word.
And I,
I was,
it was so eerie and I just kept looking
at my crew and no one's talking to each
other.
Now we're not talking to each other
because no one's talking.
It's that.
It's that law of,
you know,
whatever dictates.
I heard about it on some podcasts about,
you know,
this guy,
this guy walked into an elevator and
stood with the guy and the other way was
facing the wrong direction.
We went and looked at him.
Then it stops and someone comes in
phases while direction again.
He's was like,
Huh?
And then after the third person,
when that they face the wrong direction,
the guy who was facing the fucking doors
went fuck it.
And he just turned around because you
get into that assimilation.
Wow.
Yeah.
But uh,
it was crazy.
Japan was a mind blowing.
I did.
You like the toilets fucking blob them.
Why don't they have those everywhere.
You actually sent them to me after I
talked about it.
They're amazing.
You have during your house too?
Yeah.
You can get them.
You can buy them on Amazon.
You get them online.
It was the greatest.
I don't have them everywhere.
I would just wake up in the morning and
just cleaned my asshole.
Just sit on it and turn it on,
put on some tunes and warming up.
I rented a beach house.
It had one too.
It was Gloria,
so I was like,
yes they do is they do have one proper
feels oddly pleasurable.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we did.
We did.
We hung out with the Geisha for the
night.
Dude,
you've been all over the world like
legitimately these things.
You do.
Those scare the shit out of me when I
hear your zip lining a hundred miles an
hour.
Oh,
oh yeah.
It's some of it.
You know.
Here's the deal.
I do a panic.
Everyone knows that.
I've talked about that to everyone,
but it's hilarious that you deal with
panic and yet you do some truly
terrifying shit.
Oh Dude.
I just jumped off of Moses and the
stadium.
It's 500.
Take a look at this.
Joe.
This is me jumping off Moses from beetle
stadium and send this to Jamie.
Can we play it on the show?
Just from the.
It's from the show and the show itself.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Dude.
It's fucking 500 feet.
It's a piece of a fucking jump.
How many different trips like this have
you gone on since we started this show?
You've been doing the show for like
what?
Four years now or something?
Four years.
Have Gone on those with 14 times four.
So 50 God damn.
60 of them probably 60 plus a crazy
three adventures a day or two.
I feel like I've done everything there
is to do when it comes to adrenaline.
So yeah,
each episode you're doing numerous
things sometimes,
right?
Dude,
we've had days where you were like that
the other day in a Michigan I fucking.
And then you have like these things that
you don't want me to talk about like
we're missing.
This guy flies us out to a mackinaw
island.
It's like a hour flight.
It's not that the three,
three hour or an hour flight,
a three minute flight,
so it's not that big of a flight.
So real quick jump and we meet the guy
flying over.
I'd tell them I'm afraid to fly in.
We land.
Next morning he comes to pick us up.
We'd spend the night on the islands
snowplow,
what comes back and he says to me,
hey,
you want to fly?
So what?
He goes,
I'm an instructor.
I'll show you how to do it.
I got my two travelers with me.
You're like,
no,
don't let perfect get fly.
But in my head I'm like,
now I get the same thing that happens
with me on these jumps and all that
other stuff is where you go,
fuck,
I gotta try it like I,
I'm,
it's there.
This is a once in a life time
opportunity.
I got to fucking try it.
So I'm like,
fuck it,
let's do it.
So we've taxi down the runway and he
gets us to the position.
He was all right.
I just want to throttle and as we start
to feel lyft just start pulling back and
we just fucking take off and I've pulled
back and I'm like,
he goes and you get up to like 3000
feet,
and he's like,
all right,
2000 piece level it off and you just
start pushing forward and you feel the
plane land.
It was fucking amazing.
But those,
uh,
you know,
those are the ones aren't even on the
show.
That's just getting the special access.
It's been great.
I've been having a hard time talking
about it on stage because it sounds
alienating.
No,
I don't think so at all.
You know,
that's like a,
that's a hangup.
Like you're not an alienating guy in any
way,
just you,
you feel like it's alienating because
you're a humble guy because like you
worry,
that might sound braggy,
but it's just your life,
you know,
you're alive is interesting as fuck
dude.
I mean,
you're doing some crazy shit.
Every time I talked to you like I'm in a
shark tank in the middle of the ocean.
I'm like,
no,
you're not.
No,
Get out of that fucking thing.
We were with great white sharks.
The fuck man,
you can't be doing that itself.
Africa and the fucking the visibility we
shit so,
so they were there.
They would draw them in with a big tuna
head and then they would start up here.
The shark would just appear shark attack
attack.
We are simulating real shark attacks in
that.
They just come up on the cage and just.
So I got frustrated and I was like,
I wanted to see where the shark was so I
could predict it grew,
scare me.
So I was sitting on top of the cage and
I'm just sitting there.
We're looking for the shark and dude,
just like out of a fucking movie.
The shark leaps at the tuna head above
the water and right at me and I shit in
my wet suit.
I went fucking song and I was like
panicked,
but it was an amazing experience.
Like 14 foot shark swimming right up on
you.
You know,
dude,
I have a hard time hearing that.
I'm squirming in my chair and Shit.
There's a video that I tweeted today.
See if you can find it.
Um,
there's a guy who's poking at this roof
is a leopard that's trapped in the,
in the roof in India.
It looks like it's an India where they
do have a problem with leopards and it
has.
This guy is trying to open this thing
up.
This fucking leopard head pops out of
this little hole because it's small and
the leopard burst through the fucking
roof and starts attacking these people
and they're freaking out and trying to
run away and they're trying to hit it
with sticks and it runs into this guy
and this guy fucking pants.
It's like this crazy leopard running
around the street.
Here's a video of it,
Charlie.
Shit,
fucking kidding me.
Fucking dude is on the roof.
Okay.
So look,
there's holes in the roof and he's like
trying to figure out,
look at this.
Oh,
shut the fuck comes out of the roof and
gets after.
Oh,
oh.
It looks like a lion,
a leopard to big ass leopard spots on
it.
God.
Holy.
I mean,
it's not very high res,
but it appears to be a leopard.
Right?
Oh look,
that guy's holding the door shut in my.
Is that a tiger?
It's so hard to tell because it's
blurry,
but it looks to me like it's small and
it's fast as fuck.
Which leopards are fast as fuck.
Super aggressive.
Leopards are super aggressive.
Got Damn Dude.
Fuck all this.
Right.
I mean I react the way that guy did with
the leopard when a mouse in the house
almost like can't stabilize your fee
man.
Yeah,
that's elaborate for sure.
So it's hiding back there.
Is that what it's doing or is it killing
somebody?
I think they trapped it.
I don't know,
man.
It might have somebody in its jaws
size,
font size,
looking up.
Fuck all that man back in the house.
What kind of workout comes through?
It's his house man.
As far as he's concerned,
give a fuck.
They don't have any idea about like,
Yo,
this guy has a mortgage.
Like that shit doesn't mean anything to
a leopard.
If he finds a good spot behind a wall,
that's his house,
bitch,
come take it.
You're not a lion.
Get out of here that they're fucking
terrifying.
There was a crazy video of apparently
that happens in some parts of India all
the time and there was a crazy,
a video or a series of images rather
have this,
a guy who had a scalp removed by this
leopard.
This leopard literally clause the dude's
head.
His scalp comes off like a flap.
You find that news?
He said he's fine.
He's got all stitched up.
Just got a cool story,
but look at the size of the flap and you
realize,
oh,
these guys have razor blades on their
fingers.
It's like it just sliced them like a,
like a fucking perfect meat knife and it
all takes his.
A scent of some perfume they don't like
or you know what I mean?
Like,
but they're so.
They're so unpredictable.
Yeah.
Fuck leopards.
Fuck Jaguars leopards.
I wouldn't mind having a one of those
big savannah cats.
Well,
it was like,
dude,
just like five of them to run my back
yard.
He'd growl at you.
I liked that shit.
I just want something to on my chest in
the morning,
like John Jones,
couple of those bangles,
one of those types of cats.
He's he,
he's got them as instagram all times.
He's really big.
He takes him wear them on the road
because you have to like really like
bond with them.
You have to bond with them.
So he takes them with him.
Like when he goes to places to train and
we show it goes on like press trips and
shit like that.
Really took it to his hotel in La.
He brings that thing with them.
John John is eccentric.
It's fun.
Fuck
you.
Gotta be.
He's eccentric as fuck.
He brings a giant cat with him
everywhere.
She takes a walk.
And Elise.
Yeah.
This is the guys look at the top of his
head.
Come on son.
I see that.
Welcome to the world.
Scalped him,
man.
I mean that's like some cartoon shit and
so terrifying.
That thing is you ever cut off the tip
of your finger and then you just kind of
push it back on and just hope it just
stays.
That never happens.
Never happens.
Yeah,
that's the guy.
That's what I would've done.
Just put it back on and be like,
it doesn't happen.
Well,
they stitched that bitch back up,
but who knows if it took,
you know,
when you get a cut that big sometimes
like the blood supply is compromised,
you can get infected kind of guy that if
you lost the tip of your pinky finger
that it would affect you or does it just
become who you are and then that's a
badge of like,
like there's guys like that's like one
of,
like as far as people,
the last is that some people have
encouraged me.
That's pretty God damn small.
I think you take it like a man and you
just move on and if it comes up and go
have hell.
My pinky finger tip of my pinky finger,
I'd be like,
I'd be fucking heartbroken.
What'd you really?
But yeah,
it'd be get over it,
but she live in America.
These people in India,
they're fighting.
Giant cats are popping into the fucking
shitty house.
Their house has holes in it.
The cat's claw through.
Those aren't even the cobras.
Cobras,
all over everything,
all kinds of shit.
How about tigers?
I bought this places in India where over
the last 200 years,
300,000
people had been killed by tigers.
Tigers.
I fuck with lions,
but I wouldn't fuck with tigers.
This is the muscle aries thing to try to
save him.
It's so important that we make sure that
we keep a healthy population of machines
running to the fucking jungle that eat
people.
Let's make sure we keep them alive
there.
Super important because without them
alive,
we will be so sad.
We lost the monsters.
Monsters that were fucking crazy like
that.
Do you ever hear a concordance joke
about polar bears?
No.
I have already alerted trying to save
the polar bears.
Polar bears.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Let me tell you something.
If a polar bear came to this room,
you'd be throwing.
Your fucking chair is so true.
Horrible.
Quit cop show.
What is it?
It's on.
It's on LTV.
I think it's really good.
It is really good.
It's Colin Quinn Chapel.
It's a Colin Quinn.
It's a d.
it's like a documentary about a cop show
and column.
Quinn plays the lead cop,
but he's.
It's a documentary about his TV show and
it is fucking hilarious.
Oh,
so my documentary documentary,
and if you like Colin Quinn,
if you like quantum code a little bit,
you're going to lose your fucking mind.
He is so God damn cop show.
It's called cop show.
He's got and he's got guests on.
He had A.
Jerry Seinfeld was one of the ones that
I saw.
Jim Norton.
I'm Keith.
Keith Robinson is on all of them.
You pay to the places buddy.
I think he's like a very
underappreciated talent.
Conklin dude.
I really do.
I think he's like two people that are
intelligent.
He's fucking brilliant.
But to just really stupid people like
that shit ain't even funny.
Like they,
there's,
there's a lot of stupid people that on
his twitter,
like they miss all the jokes,
like if,
you know his style of humor,
you know,
how he's like,
he's observed but barely,
you know,
to the point where like he's,
he's obviously fucking with you,
but he's doing it cleverly,
you know,
and when he does it's like if you know
collins type of humor and you're a fan
of his,
it becomes really,
really funny.
It's like he's patrolling everyone on
the Internet.
Jay Moore does a fucking fantastic.
Colin,
his columns.
Creepy down point.
Collins a unique dude.
He's,
I really feel like he's underappreciated
because he's been around a long goddamn
time.
He was on tv back when fucking he was on
remote control,
wasn't he?
He was on TV when I was in high school.
Yeah.
And I'm an old man.
Yeah,
he was on TV when I was an open mic or
I'm pretty sure I remember him being on
TV.
He's been around a long time.
We did a,
we did an episode but trip flip with
Colin Quinn.
He was on it and what we were going to
have people to stand up and so we said,
what we'll do.
I said,
call,
I'll give you the mic and then I'll put
an ifb and our guys here and then you
just tell them the jokes to say and
he'll say I'm right.
I was like,
perfect.
So I was like,
all right,
let's test it out.
So we put this kid in the room and
calling the other room and I go,
all right,
let's go.
And we had completely forgotten that
Colin Quinn is so fucking funny that
when you hear him talk,
you'll fall apart laughing.
Right?
So the kid couldn't say anything because
he's just doubled over.
I was like,
what he was doing was making fun of me.
He's like,
what's this guy?
An extra wwf wrestler.
What's up with the beard?
Just destroying me calling.
I think con tough crowd is one of my
favorite shows ever.
No.
Keith Robinson and I'm rich Vos and
Bonnie Mcfarlane.
We're talking about that the other day
on their podcast,
it was on why?
It might have been their show.
They were on Xm,
but they were,
uh,
they were talking and you're taking
calls and stuff and they were talking
about how like,
there's a different kind of mentality,
at least in La,
at the clubs,
all the mean comics have died off like
that.
Fun,
mean Shit.
Well,
you don't really mean it,
but it's hilarious just tearing each
other apart.
That stuff has died off for some reason
and it's been replaced by.
Bonnie said it best.
She said it was like an acting class
sort of a vibe that every good to see
you.
I really enjoyed you on this.
I really thought you were me.
She goes,
it's like this weird alt crowd is coming
over and he's like this air of phoniness
about at all that you get from like
acting class and like acting classes
filled with people that are trying to
like posture them.
Someone's real actress too.
But you know what I'm saying?
There's a few people in every fucking
acting class that are trying really hard
to become that stereotypical
prototypical California actor where they
don't say here's one of the things they
don't say.
They don't say nice to meet you because
they might already met you,
so they say good to see you.
Oh yes,
yes.
I'll say it.
They all fucking say you.
Listen.
You can't say that.
You can't say good to see you unless
you've seen me again.
It's like good to see you again.
Oh again.
What is.
Where's the again?
Good to see you.
It's good to see everything.
It's good and to not be blind.
I agree.
Good to see you.
Or you see me for the first time.
How many times you think you've seen me
before?
How many times we met motherfucker.
Do you know me better?
So?
No,
no.
You don't know you're fucking fraud.
Imagine that you said.
Yeah,
we met before.
Fuck.
We have never met before.
Good to see you.
What does that mean you noncommittal?
Fuck Dude.
At my kids' school.
They drop off.
I'm talking to my buddy John and some
guy goes,
hey,
what's up?
Hey Chris.
My Buddy John was just talking to my
buddy,
John Girl.
Data happens all the time.
I've done that before.
And you go,
oh no.
Did I say Steve File?
Have to tell them I know her.
I fucking hate that on probably think.
I think to Steve,
that's why I call everyone blue for the
same reason because I'm fucking myself
over so many times and when you fuck
yourself over the wrong or Comedians,
they're always going to remember that
like motherfucker call me jeff or
something like that.
You know?
People have a hard time letting go of a
hard time remembering names.
Yeah,
of course you do.
Well that's the thing.
There's a certain number that you have
in your head and you get past that
number and it's called Dunbar's number.
150 people in your head.
That's it.
So you got room for fuck.
You get more than 150 people.
You got to delete names.
Like you can't have like friendships
with more than 150 people.
You just don't have the data base.
I think I spent those numbers up in like
third grade.
When I look at the yearbook and look at
the kids older than me,
they're still people older than me in
Berkeley prep high grade school that I
remember them distinctly.
Sure.
I remember looking at those pictures and
seeing the hot girls,
Holly Clifford,
and now I still remember her.
I remember was her picture.
It looked like people that had an impact
on you.
You're going to remember them for sure.
You're always going to remember them,
but people that like if you meet a bunch
of people on a daily basis,
like how many people you're meeting,
you're talking about you did 60 fucking
shows and how many people are on each
show?
That's like 120 people already.
Right?
So that's no way.
There's no way you gonna remember all
them.
It's unfortunate.
Like there's people that were on fear
factor and I'll meet him again and I'll
go,
what the fuck?
Where do I know?
I try to remember where I know we did
the thing with the bowl and the guy,
oh yeah,
oh hey man,
how are you doing?
And then all of a sudden,
like,
I have access to those files again,
like my brain will go,
yeah,
yeah.
Let me pull that up here.
It is like in my regular brain,
my regular memory,
it just wasn't available.
But your brain will give you access to
these files if you pull them up every
now and then.
Like if you delete certain things,
you could still find them like they're
in your trash but you have an empty your
trash yet saying it gives you a chance
to pull them back.
But I think it gets to a certain point
and then you no more.
There's no more file does not exist.
Yeah,
I'm done.
I'm done with the files and now I'm
dreaming so much,
so intensely that I'm literally like
going through every morning and I'm like
fucking 13 dreams that are remembering.
And that's kind of fucking with my day.
Are you having so many dreams?
I have no idea,
man.
I think I broke my gov with that.
Uh,
with the lucid,
like I got really into
lucid dreaming and I was lucid dreaming
constantly.
Still am today.
Last night had a dream about I'm getting
arrested at the Hillsborough River Lake
with a bunch of my friends and I was in
my underwear and they had the dogs
putting us down and then I woke up and
they'd thrown tear gas at us and the
dogs were standing over us and we're
handcuffed and that's like me and four
friends spread out and I woke up and I
went,
I'm not done with that cop because I'm,
I'm wanting to.
I needed to do justice in that dream.
And so I went back to sleep and I just
started dreaming immediately about that
cop.
So this is something that we actually
talked about this.
Did we talk about this?
We have Alpha brain and what I've
realized is my,
my,
my lucid dreaming is attached to Alpha
brain in the sense that our would give
me energy and make me think quicker and
faster.
I don't know if it was caffeine or what
was in it.
Um,
but,
um,
but no caffeine,
it's probably colding.
Acetylcholine is something that people
reported.
If you take it,
it gives you a really intense dreams.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
one of the universal things that people
said about Alpha brain is the dream
part.
I've always said it makes,
it feels like I got,
I don't,
I'm not a lucid dreamer where I don't
have any techniques and practice it,
but occasionally I found myself in that
state and when I find myself in that
state where I realized that I'm
dreaming,
it feels like it's more,
it's,
it always used to feel like a child's
bubble.
You know,
when you blow a bubble,
like if you touch it,
it pops.
It became like a basketball.
Like I could bounce this motherfucker
around like this dream.
I could bounce it around.
I never pursued it.
You pursued it,
you got into the techniques in you,
you got into like getting your mind in
the right state.
No,
no.
Just blacking out and passing out drunk.
But I mean you said you got in lucid
dream practicing it.
Right.
The thing is is that I,
I found myself waking up and being able
to get back into dreams and then I went,
there's something to that.
Then I found myself for a big chunk of
big,
big chunk being in a dream state for
almost the entire night without
sleeping.
Like,
I mean I put this on the sensitivity of
my fitbit watch.
I put it on the sensitivity,
very sensitive when I sleep I'm always
sleeping really like sleeping like three
to four hours a night.
But I'm,
I'm out the whole night.
But I'm having these intense really,
um,
uh,
in like all encompassing dreams,
you know,
like,
and,
and I was weaving my way in and out of
them.
I was having my way with them.
I mean,
there were like,
it was like next level.
I talked about it on a podcast.
It was Shane Moss and I ended up.
But he asked me,
I told him and then I ended up crying in
the middle of,
this is about buddy who killed himself,
but it was such a surreal fucking dream
that I,
that even telling anyone about it,
they're like,
how the fuck did that?
Like,
are you serious?
Did you ever think about like reading
books on it and getting deep into the
methods that people use to achieve those
states?
I did,
I did online.
I've read a bunch about dreaming online.
Um,
and I even took it as far as how I
became obsessed with it and I wanted to
do a dream cast right.
Bring in like a Zen Buddhist monk to
relax you and get you to sleep.
And then for like for like seven minutes
we get you to sleep and then give you a
period of two minutes silent.
And then I am like the dream weaver and
I'm like,
well,
all right guys,
we're in like.
And so as you're sleeping,
because it happens to me a lot.
I know I've told you that I'll have
dreams of you.
I dream of viewing fitzsimmons hanging
out in my living room talking and I just
was,
you guys all my podcasts and I was
sleeping and it was just immersing
itself in my head.
Wow.
And it's like,
it was so funny because whatever you
guys were talking about,
I had an opinion and I kept trying to
interrupt you guys.
And you were like,
hold on bird bird,
stop how bizarre.
But yeah,
I,
I'm dreaming for me is like I,
it's if I feel like I need it in life in
order to stay sane because my dreams are
like fucking literally when I say 13
dreams tonight that I remember sometimes
30 dreams.
Like damn dude,
I remember.
I remember what will happen is I'll tell
you one.
And then as I tell you one,
it will untangle all the other ones.
Start.
It'll,
it'll start coming out like,
like,
like a braid.
You'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
And then.
And so,
uh,
I called Doug Benson,
remember my dreams are so intense.
At one point I was,
Doug Benson asked me to leave them to
him on his answering machine.
So I leave him on his answering machine
now.
And then he puts them on.
Doug loves minis.
So we put my dreams on Douglas.
Like I came in,
like,
like I had a dream one time.
This is what my funnier dreams as an
answering machine.
It's his voicemail voicemail,
this car phone to call his answering
machine.
Had a dream one time that,
uh,
I'm standing like this.
Okay.
I'm onstage and I'm standing like this.
Hands on the hips,
a very feminine,
more flamboyantly gay than feminine.
If a woman did that,
you'd be confused.
So I look and I'm like,
what the fuck?
And there's a curtain right in front of
me and I'm like,
what is this?
And I looked to the left and I see four
dudes staggard stance to it with me,
two behind us in Klan outfits,
a Klux Klan outfits.
And I look and sometimes there'll be a
mirror on the side of the stages.
I look and I see me,
I'm not in a clean up it,
but I'm hauling white and I've got a
dunce cap on and I'm like,
that's close enough.
That's like,
even if I don't look just like them
people I was in,
I'm in the dream.
I thought travel channel's going to be
pissed when they see that I'm dancing
with,
with like and all of a sudden I hear the
curtains start to pull back and I'm
about to get off stage and I hear ladies
and gentlemen put your hands together
for the click clack cleanse and we start
tap dancing and I've always wanted to
tap dance and we start tap dancing and
just fucking hammering it out.
I'm like,
I can't.
CanNot stay.
Just so much fun.
And then I woke up and I was like,
Benson,
I had a dream to be a great sketch.
The click clack clans should write this
down.
I've lived on Doug Benson's answering,
make a sketch out about these guys that
were in the clan,
but they feel bad.
They don't hate black people anymore and
they want to entertain and spread their
new message.
They clicked so they start,
they start going around the country,
tap dancing and align the way they
encounter so many black people.
They can become racist again.
Turned back around and people get really
mad.
Crowes people
really mad at them because they're used
to being the clan like fucking bill,
but we're not in the cloud anymore.
I'm telling you we're not racist.
We have a total change of heart.
And we already had the costumes.
That's why we're wearing.
No,
we're just,
we're just being big foods as the class.
By the end of it,
they were like,
fuck black people back.
I'm back.
I'm moving back to Tennessee.
I moved back to the mountains,
back to deep woods to click clack clams.
There was a period of my dreams,
like a big chunk where they were like
cyclical and uh,
and had amazing endings like,
and I was just like,
I was blown away and I was telling
Benson,
he was like,
leave me on my thing and I'll put them
on my podcast.
So I started doing it.
And then what happens is I'm going
through this right now as I go through a
big period.
I was leaving them a lot of malaria
dreams because they're insane.
And then I get,
I'm so.
I'm so keyed into dreaming.
I'm dreaming obsessively where I am
right now,
where I'm having like fucking 30 to 35 a
night and I can't stop them.
You haven't been able to remember all 35
of them?
Yeah,
I mean obviously even if I listen to my
dreams now,
if I go to doug loves movies and listen
to my dreams,
put all your dreams on Doug Benson's
podcast.
Why don't you just because you have
burt's dreams.
I didn't have a separate podcast or just
inch at a time.
It was just came out organically and I
was like,
people got fucking.
Hate them all.
Throw my podcast.
But does he have commercials on that?
Oh yeah.
He's making money off if bird streams.
He's making money off your dreams.
I'm just kidding.
Anyway,
it's Berclov Minis.
It's like a five minute.
Just catch up for the week.
Anyway,
it felt pure fucking papers here,
Bert and getting fucked over here.
Business Wise,
I feel like you're getting fucked.
Anyway.
Commercials on camera dreams.
Interesting.
Yeah,
I'm thinking,
I've been thinking of doing that.
I've been thinking about doing a big,
long one of all my dreams for him
because they're just,
they're just release a podcast where you
wake up and you explain in great detail.
I mean,
you could do 15 minutes,
20 minutes,
whatever,
and just release it as a podcast,
but we would love that.
The,
um,
if you really haven't that many a night
dream catcher,
make it a cool journey.
Time capture streams.
How about podcasts?
Just real simple.
Burt's dreams are you talking about your
dreams?
Every single episode is a drain and
that's it.
There's no sports towards your dreams.
All your dreams like you could do,
you know,
you could do how they tie in together.
What you did before you went to bed,
what you drank that put you in this
catatonic state.
We believe that you're in a bubble bath.
That's the size of the Philadelphia
Eagles Stadium floating in there and
you're naked,
but no one could see you because the
water's so high.
I mean,
you,
you could have a bunch of different
fucking crazy dreams that you can just
relay.
You could have your kids tell their
dreams or you could tell their kids to
have it.
I would burn the boats of dreams.
It usually,
like lately all my dreams had been
comics,
like all my dreams,
a bit about comics.
I had a dream about you and Debby Norton
and
bill burn a bunch of guys in a radio
show like two nights,
two nights ago and so.
But it's like all.
They're all about comics right now.
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I honestly doing the road a lot I think
because I haven't been doing stand up as
much as I'm able to stand up and so now
I've started back on stand up and I
think I'm just inspired by a bunch of
people who I feel like are doing it a
lot better than me.
So.
So when you said you haven't been doing
standup as much as you've been doing
standup,
I think you probably met when doing the
show more than doing tv more than.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
You put me in a weird quagmire when we
had the conversation of Vietnam,
as I said.
All right.
So I've been very attentive to writing
material about these things that had
been doing and I've been going back and
looking at all the activities.
However,
a few like,
um,
I feel like it's really interesting,
you know,
so often you hear comics come on the
podcast,
they'll talk about writing new material
and Jimmy,
you're getting a beer.
Oh,
writing new material and,
and,
and the versus the addiction of killing,
you know.
And uh,
and I think I'd always thought because I
write on stage,
I'm like,
yeah,
I always right,
I'm not worried about that.
But then this weekend I was in Columbus
and they noticed that when I would get
into a spot where it was a genuine new
bit about scuba diving,
80 feet to go see a wrecker or a,
we're riding the top fuel dragster
jumping off this most of a Meta stadium
that when it started a bomb,
that's the panic feeling where people
go,
I need to get out and do an old bit.
And to be able to own that bomb and
sitting there and trust it and trust it
that these people are going to get a
piece of shit joke right now that I'm
working on,
but trust me one day it'll be better.
Was there for.
It's for writing.
You got to,
you know,
that's where you should really fuck
around and try to expand bits,
trying to come up with new ways to do
them.
You take a lot of chances.
And like club Gaffigan and I had a
conversation about this who was kind of
interesting.
He's just like,
I always do new shit,
but I always want to make sure the show
is good.
Yeah,
that's the most important thing.
I'm not going to go up there and do a
new,
like completely new stuff and bomb.
It was like if it's all going bad,
I will go to old stuff that I know it
really works.
He's like the most important thing for
me is that the show's good,
which makes a lot of sense.
Especially if they're paying high ticket
dollar prices in theaters,
which is like a lot of stuff he's doing.
He's got a kind of pretty big obligation
to have a good show.
People got babysitters.
They came out there.
That's where the La clubs come in.
That's where [inaudible] comes in here,
you know,
at the store,
at the Improv,
which is going up and you know,
I'm just going up with a skeleton of a
joke and trying to figure out what it
isn't.
Recording it,
listening to it,
going back over it or record it.
You record it.
You got an iphone.
Just use your phone.
I still hard to do.
Well,
no.
Yeah,
I don't know it.
I feel like when I recorded,
I actually say it differently than if I
feel.
If it's getting lost to the ethos,
then I feel like it's a,
it's in the,
it's in the spirit.
It's in the moment and it's in live by
the sword,
die by the sword type shit.
You like doing that.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Just takes longer to get a bit better.
Yeah.
The reality of recording
is if you do it all the time,
you're not going to say it any
different.
If you're recording every set that I
have a record,
so every set is is like when it's 100%
of your sets,
it's never different because you're
recording what I'm saying,
like it just becomes doing a set,
so if I say something in the middle of I
don't have to ponder afterwards,
what did I say?
What did I say?
I a recording because there's a lot of
times where you're saying things off the
cuff and that's the line.
That's the line and dude,
if you're not recording that line can
escape you.
It can leave you and never return it.
You could take yourself into some
strange place,
strange headspace because when you're
doing a bit something might happen or
someone might react to it in a certain
way and because they react to it in a
certain way,
you say,
well,
you're thinking the and that's the best
line of the joke and that just came out
of that particular moment.
If you don't capture that,
you might not ever be able to recreate
it in your memory because you're in that
weird zen state when you're killing too.
That's part of the problem,
like when you're really in the groove,
you're in that zen state where you're
barely there,
you know,
you like a ride on this thing and when
you're creating all those new bits in
that sort of zen state,
a lot of times you can't remember what
you said.
Yeah.
I usually end up saying out loud,
if I say something new that's really
good.
I'll go.
Can someone please tweet that to me?
That works.
Yeah.
So friend tweeted me a Sushi,
your kids sucking Dick.
I was like,
what the fuck?
by the end of the night I'm hammered.
It was,
it was the idea that I was,
I don't know how the big goes because I
said it in the moment,
but I'll figure it out.
But uh,
that,
um,
two guys,
two guys watching gay porn is like
giving your kid Sushi for the first
time.
Like,
I don't think I like it.
And you're like,
don't put in your mouth.
See what you think.
Maybe you like getting like now and the
texture is going to freak me out.
I heard it's expensive.
That's so funny.
Yeah,
hurting.
Get sick.
Yeah.
People if they get sick,
they always blamed Sushi.
I got diarrhea.
I eat Sushi,
Sushi.
Are you sure?
Sure.
How the fuck do you know you eat things
all day,
Joe?
You know that's what's funny about that
is that it's almost impossible to get
food poisoning from Sushi because in
United States Sushi is flash frozen.
It has to be frozen and then I re falled
out,
so it's like almost impossible for you
to actually.
That's not totally true.
There's certainly certain ones can get
parasites rooms,
especially freshwater fish,
but when people get sick,
it's from the rice.
I bet some people get sick from the
salmon to certain freshwater fishes.
Parasites,
salt,
water,
fish.
You don't really have to worry about it
as much,
but the freshwater fish drink goat's
blood with a chief the other day,
like I just have.
I've given up on any of that fucking
I've been because I'm nervous eater
about stuff like that.
Gross blood cut its throat,
poured it into a horn,
put some grass in there,
shook it up,
gave it to me like why grass?
It's not disgusting by itself.
Some grass high enough historic mix.
That shit up.
Goldblatt,
who's your go blood Hyena Piss smoothie.
Irony.
It tasted like a liver was real.
It was real myron.
He could feel it like 10 out of your
mouth a little bit.
Trying to make sense,
man.
That's a hard scrabble life.
Being a goat.
Goats live in places where there's not a
lot of water right now.
There's no fucking water where we where
they can survive a long time with no
water.
Those mountain goats,
they must taste like shit.
Tastes like it.
Tastes great.
You eat them.
We put them on skewers,
had a fire and then had the skewers
angled from the fire and just cooked.
It was interesting.
That's the way they cook.
I learned to that.
That's where they cooked.
Medium rare too.
Well done is they stick that stick in
the fire that way and it cooks or
something.
They'll say,
I found I was meditating with a Zen
Buddhist priest and in Japan they stick
to it so that there's a fire.
They stick the stick in this way and
that's how this is more well done and
this is less well done.
So that's how they cook it.
You listened to people that are
listening to this,
so try to explain this in a way that
makes sense.
So if you're confused and I'm right in
front of you,
you build a fire.
I said,
look at that on paper.
People are like,
what the fuck is he saying?
Let's just mark it off to.
I wasn't listening and I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about is a stick.
They stick it in the fire and then put
the meat on the stick.
The skewer,
the stick,
the meat on a small size have this big
sport that's like fucking this long.
It's fucking sharp shit.
They stay.
Make it sharpest shit and thin.
So they make a stick.
They turn into a bar and then they
basically skewer all the goat's meat on
a stick,
like,
like a Kabob and then they shove it
right next to the fire,
like two o'clock on a,
on a clock.
They,
we put them all around the.
They put it all around the fire,
really,
like just like hands one o'clock and
then,
but they're angled out.
I still angled pointing away and I said,
that's interesting.
And he said,
well no,
the top ones aren't as well done in the
bottoms that are more well done.
I thought that was really fucking
fascinating.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
My head,
I'm like,
I can just grill my shit like I could
actually be.
But then I talked to him about wood and
it's really specific about what kind of
wood you use.
Cancers,
use any wood,
so there's certain different types of
wood that people will cook with.
Especially in Africa.
That's in America too.
Like there's like if you watch those
barbecue contests,
you ever see those barbecue?
Compress those gates.
Fascinated those.
Get you wanting to smoke a meet dudes.
Smoke a brisket.
Like a cherry tree.
Cherry tree do.
We had fucking beal,
a venison sausage.
I eat venison sausage some.
I got some in my house is one of my
favorites.
Delicious.
To mix pork fat into it though.
It's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Most venison sausages.
Not really.
Venison sausage,
it's venison sausage with pork fat,
like,
um,
I Cook Ground Venison,
I take ground venison and I cook it and
I'll use like gluten free pasta or like
sprouted grain pasta and I'll mix it all
together
with like some tomato sauce.
It's fucking fantastic.
But it's one of the rare times where
people use ground venison by itself.
Most ground venison,
they mix up with pork fat because it's
so lean because it's a healthy animal.
I mean it's an animal that's running
around eating crops and grass and
Alfalfa and shit and running all over
the place.
They don't have much body fat on them.
So when you,
if you had just,
just the meat of the deer in the
sausage,
it would probably be really dry.
He wouldn't like it.
Listen,
I've had a bunch of medicine as of late.
I just fucking love it.
It's really good for you,
dude.
You know what's the best though?
Elk elks.
Insane.
I need to get one of those.
I need.
I'm,
I'm going on to Elkanns this fall.
Really?
Fuck.
Yeah.
They have a problem with wolves.
They've killed so many elk that there's
certain populations,
certain parts of a America where the elk
population has dropped down to 20% of
its original size.
What's his name?
Rinella.
Talking about that on your podcast.
There's places where like,
you know,
there's,
it's dropped 50%,
but you know,
there's still a lot of elk is a lot of
elk.
It's just about getting near them.
There's so many of them.
Like my friend Helen,
Helen Cho,
she's the.
I'm a woman who works for a 0.0.
She works with Anthony Bordain.
She works with Steve or Noah and his
show and they,
uh,
they took her hunting for the first time
and she's a,
she's been here a bunch of times hanging
out with us when Ronelle has come on.
And she's like super sweet,
like,
you know,
grew up in Brooklyn and unreal Nela
show.
He took her hunting,
her and another woman who works in the
office,
they took the,
both of them with my friend Ryan
Callahan and Rinella,
and they took them into Montana.
That shooting elk.
But you see like these herds developed
with.
He was like 50,
60,
70,
80,
or a hundred elk,
like giant herds of these cow elks,
and so she picks one out and she drops
it and she,
you know,
they cooked it that night.
It was crazy.
It's crazy watching,
knowing her,
knowing her as a person that's like,
you know,
didn't really have a lot of experience
outdoors at all.
It wasn't like a crazy fitness person or
an extreme athlete is doing naughty
things all the time.
Like she,
you know,
as a regular person,
very nice person,
works in an office,
you know,
works for Anthony Bourdain and 0.0
and all of a sudden she's shooting a
fucking elk in the mountains of Montana
and the snow and the woods and it's like
wild shit dude.
Did you,
did you like cry or anything?
She was pretty.
Not Cry,
but you could tell she was like real.
It was like an overwhelming experience.
She was like,
there's no words for this.
Which is how I felt too.
The first time I shot a deer.
It's like,
there's no words for this.
This is wild.
So it's not like hitting a home run.
Nah,
Nah.
Hitting a home run.
There's no sense of loss.
There's a weird sense of loss when you,
uh,
when you shoot an animal like a,
you're going to eat that animal so you
don't feel bad about it.
Um,
at least I didn't feel bad about it.
I thought about it for so long before I
actually did it.
But there's a sense of loss.
When can we hit a home run?
It's all like,
Yay.
Be
nothing else to die.
When you're getting an animal and you've
got your hands inside its body and you
feel the hot body cavity.
It's really weird.
Buffalo,
one time we shot it up on crow nation.
It was hard.
It was,
it was tough.
What show was this trip?
We went hunting with the crow,
really shut a buffalo buffalo up on the,
up on a perch,
like a sniper was with the whole pack
and they have to keep the male
population down because it fucks with it
so they know which one they're shooting
and they go out and they pop it back in.
What was really fascinating to me,
and I was either the small details of a
story of overwhelming,
like when like the little thing that you
won't will,
you wouldn't normally talk about the
story,
but what was funny to me was the kind of
the gallows humor that Crow Indians had
as they were gutting the l gutting the
buffalo.
Like did,
they weren't disrupting disrespectful of
the animal,
but like I guess they cut you cut out
it's asshole.
Yeah.
And then they like that.
But they were laughing as they cut up
the asphalt.
It's kids first time cutting the asshole
out and it was like kind of an
interesting,
like almost like morbid humor,
like comics kind of humor.
Like you couldn't offend anyone in that
circle.
And then when they were like,
put your hand in Buffalo.
And I was like,
oh no,
and then I can't do it.
Be a man.
And they had a little kid put his hand
in there.
You've got to feel it.
It's an animal.
It was a,
it was just alive.
So I was like,
fuck it.
So I got to do it.
Put my hand in there and it just Kinda
took me over.
I was like,
Oh fuck,
this is,
this is human warm like this is way
warmer.
But it's like,
yeah,
it was hot and it was really kind of.
I Dunno if blew me away,
but I always,
when I kept saying in my head I was,
it was similar to being a comic because
comics can't get offended.
So there was no,
like,
there was no pc police,
they're just killed an animal.
You're all in this together.
So,
uh,
it's like I was overwhelmed.
And then we ate the buffalo that night.
It was fucking fantastic.
I buffaloes to loose dude the best meat
for you to leaner than chicken.
And then chicken super high in protein.
It's,
it tastes better than the beef.
It's really good man.
Fuck gses.
But especially if they have a good diet.
Chia seeds,
Chia seeds right now.
It's the biggest mistake I ever fucking
made her drink those chia drinks.
Nobody.
I'm just swallowing the seeds whole like
Taylor swift to that man.
Get to get these cheer drinks.
I forget what it's named,
but it's like Chia and the in between
there's some juice or something like
that.
Slips down,
right?
Real easy and it's actually tastes good
and it's super healthy for you.
Apparently the reason I was eating and
expand in your stomach and so they make
you feel full faster.
But uh,
and,
but then you just shit Bibi's.
I mean you're saying a thousand ants.
You want to lose weight?
Dude,
this is the only way buddy.
Don't take fucking emailed me this here.
You got to let this go.
No,
don't say texted me the other night.
I'm like,
was like,
hey bro,
what's up?
Or on twitter.
I was like,
I'm fat as fuck.
Can you fix this?
I sent a picture of you fix this,
fix it.
Let everybody knows how to fix it.
Nobody wants to fix it,
man.
They all want to talk about fixing it.
Yeah.
Wants to talk about fixing
it and stay almost exactly the same
weight pretty much forever.
A few people break loose from the herd
and become thin and they're like,
how the fuck did you do it man?
And they're like,
man,
I just didn't eat bullshit.
That's crazy that you did that.
I just cut back on the Cheetos ice cream
and soda and fucking melted off me.
Come on.
I want to maintain my lifestyle and
simply add in more activity and hope
that it disappears that way.
You need to burn off insane amounts of
calories.
That's what people don't understand.
If you want to get your body to a point
where it's burn off fat,
you got burn off more calories than
you're taking in.
It's like super simple.
But most people aren't willing to do
that.
Is not willing to eat less than your
body needs.
What?
No,
I'm still hungry.
What kind of bullshit is this?
Could suck my dick and get crazy.
And he started eating cookies and next
thing you know,
die has gone.
Just no know.
Like I get those moments where I see
like Oreos and I just go to fucking milk
right next to him is still like someone
pours a glass of milk and Oreos.
Like if they're fucking with you have
the trying to get you to do they do that
shit.
I'm like,
the biggest loser they put like kick in
isn't the biggest loser was the one
where they had the big table,
but Faye,
where they have to go around and they'd
go,
no,
no.
Shows positive.
I've been watching the biggest loser all
the time.
They never incorporate unhealthy
lifestyle and whatsoever they would ever
tempt them.
With that.
The show was a celebrity,
celebrity,
fat person,
a celebrity,
fat fuck.
That would be great.
Recession.
Every fat fuck.
They didn't find out the name of the
show until the first day when they line
them all up,
they're like,
gentlemen are people.
I'd like to welcome you to the celebrity
fat fucking just watch small.
Go,
oh man.
Fuck my agents at as whole.
You know what's interesting about a fat,
this is the reality about diets is that
everybody doesn't get an even starting
point and that's what's not fair.
Some people just get weird bodies that
just like,
are you looking at me?
She like little babies,
like little chubby babies.
Like my daughter was in this dance
class.
It's a little girls with her when she's
little.
She was like,
you know,
two,
three years old.
There's other little two,
three year olds with.
Some of them are just fat as fuck.
Some of them,
their parents are fat.
The parents sit down there and they
struggle to sit.
They sit down and this kid wattles out
there and dances.
You're like,
whoa.
Like this kid doesn't even get a chance.
Like from jump,
she's overweight,
she's carrying all this body fat food
that,
that fit kids getting fed.
I'm sure it also could be whatever the
parents heating certainly could be,
but you could feed that to my kid and
they would burn it right off.
It's weird.
It's not even,
it's not even my uh,
oldest daughter.
So like super skinny man.
I'm in
the middle one actually.
She's super skinny.
Like she,
she like is always thin,
really thin and she eats whatever she
wants.
She never has to worry about it.
She's always wants another scoop of ice
cream and you know,
we don't restrict.
We give them like mostly healthy food,
but we don't restrict the shit.
I don't believe in restricting things,
I believe like and also reminding them
after the ice cream how they feel like
shit,
you know,
like after the United States.
I'm like,
that was good.
Right?
It tasted good,
but damn,
I feel tired now.
Do you feel tired?
I don't feel tired when ice cream.
While your body's not supposed to have
that much sugar.
Like it sucks because it tastes really
good.
It does suck.
I'm like,
yeah,
I know.
It's weird.
It's a weird trick.
We plan ourselves.
I want her to know about that trick when
she's six,
not when she's 26 and she's throwing up
in the toilet to try to stay thin.
You know?
I want them just like it's good to have
fatty foods is fun.
Sometimes it's not.
It's not.
I don't believe it's good to miss out on
all the pleasures in life because some
people get hooked on them.
I say,
I think that's horseshit.
Like Bacon is fucking delicious.
Now I will never stop eating bacon.
It's not going to fucking happen.
It's too good.
When I sit there and I'm chewing on a
crispy piece of Bacon,
this cooked maybe just a little too
long,
but it's just crunching on my mouth and
the saltiness and the sweetness of the
pig fat that's just warm and melting in
my mouth as I chew it down,
breaking down the,
the,
the crispy fat.
I'm not stopping now that
tube,
if you bake bacon,
had like four,
25,
20,
whatever it is.
The perfect.
I mean it's translucent and it melts in
your mouth and I swear to God of
dictates like that might not have
bruised knees.
Like,
I fucking love Bacon.
I was I telling you today,
I haven't had a bruised knees.
I fucking love that.
Robb Wolf is one of the Paleo Diet
pioneer guys.
Just sorta genius fitness health guy.
He slow cooks bacon every morning.
He's like ritual.
He gets that fat bacon from whole foods
and you know those big ass dude and he
puts on this like fucking slow baking
cooker and he's like,
as I'm getting ready for my day,
I'm going through my day.
It's smelling the Aromas,
filling the house.
It's like a,
there's a bunch of experiences going on
and I'm like,
God damn,
these poor vegans,
poor bastard,
my wife,
my wife.
You know how like women have since like
a women who have a sense when you start
dating and relating and showing to
smells like strawberry smells like bacon
chick.
One time that smell like fucking
Bologna.
I was like Dana for two years process,
but my wife smells like bacon every
morning.
She makes the same thing.
She's southern bacon,
eggs,
biscuits and fruit for the kids.
Every fucking morning could call.
Good call.
That's a good baptist.
My House reeks.
I've even taken my bacon game to the
next level.
When you
go to buy your Bacon,
if you buy it like just a regular story,
they have the cut you get.
Don't get the thick cut that spread out
like playing cards,
like,
like fanned out,
get the thick cut that's packed in like
dollar bills and then look at this.
You've got to make sure that the
beginning to the end of that fit cut is
even.
You don't want any dips in it.
Go for fucking straight.
Even that's the most amount of bacon you
can get for your money.
I'm taking my baby.
I'm taking my pink and pretty seriously
needs to go to a butcher.
That's when you take him to the next
level,
right?
When you're really taking the next
level.
When you raise your own fucking pigs
walk,
raise your own pigs,
get friendly with him and shoot him
right in the head because that's what
you gotta do.
We had this guy on the podcast name is
Joel Salitan and he's like a pretty
famous farmer for writing books about
farming and he tries to recreate natural
environments as much as possible and one
of the things he does with his pigs as
he puts them all inside a movable fence,
so the fence is enormous.
All the pigs are inside of this and then
he moves the fence and so the fence
moves to a new area and the pigs route
around eat acorns and nuts and all kinds
of shit.
And then after,
you know,
x amount of days,
they moved the fence to a new area.
So the pigs have a totally new area to
grace.
He has this enormous plot of land that
he does all this on and it's all like a
little electric fences to keep the pigs
in,
but the pigs are more like a wild pig.
They have like a dark texture to me,
but they're super healthy,
but they maintain the same sort of
characteristics of domesticated pigs
where they're not freaked out by people.
Not like fucking trying to run from me
all the time.
I thought I thought what you described
as like to remember Daniel Russo's a
halloween costume and the karate kid
shower,
that he could walk around and don't see
them.
I thought it would.
That was the fence.
Like the pink pigs could move them.
That's funny.
Look like a three d term tabling.
The pigs could just keep walking their
fence around like a walker or.
That's funny and I was like a fucking
genius and then all of a sudden they
pigs are in town and they're all on that
fence.
The guys got to come put a fucking tow
hitch on the fence.
Do one day they'll the oculus rift for
pigs.
They put it on them in the fucking.
What are you doing,
Jamie?
Danny Lussos costume for the chronic
kids.
Oh,
Daniel Russo.
Yeah,
I remember it.
I used to have a joke.
Don't you think at one point,
uh,
at some point Danny Lewis was.
Mom would've been like,
I think this maintenance man.
I mean this man is trying to fuck my son
spend a lot of times Japanese guys
making paint his house.
It comes.
His knees are bruised.
His hands when he's painting for them.
This is some weird fetish thing.
Slave wax on,
wax off.
Wait a minute.
You're waxing his car or he's teaching
you karate.
It's one of the other people who had
this idea that somehow or another like
painting a fence is going to help you
fight.
That was the dumbest fucking movie.
His catch fucking flies with chopsticks.
Shit.
That ruined a lot of people with karate
before it started us.
That's the first movie I ever cried at
fucking sob.
We were in Taiwan,
chancy old yeller.
I credit that to.
But that was before that.
I've a lot of movies cried.
I cried onstage at the Columbus funny
bone telling people about my time.
Traveler's wife,
just telling,
I said,
I came and talked about it.
Someone was a fan of the podcast.
I was like,
right if I came and talking about I'll
start crying if I start telling you
about the movie or the movie miracle
about the US hockey team.
I started sobbing uncontrollably.
Which one is more emotional?
One about the guys getting this,
that or the guy goes back in time and
they're equal.
What is the premise of time travel?
I'm not doing this.
Just tell me what it is.
I'm going to google it.
I'll tell you,
don't google it because it's going to
take forever.
Tell me what it is.
It's a guy who learns how to talk.
He time traveled.
He's totally hit a certain time,
right?
But the day his mom dies who time
travels,
and it turns out that in times of
stress,
he time to travel,
so he also has a drinking problem
because when he drinks,
he doesn't time travel.
So births in relating to this guy.
Thank you joe.
I'm so glad you see it this way.
And so Eric Bana.
Oh dude loves him and everything else
got too high.
Song as the hulk,
like homeboys phone in and not liking
it.
I maintained that hamstring does career,
no pun intended.
That hamstring performance for that.
He did that fucking movie where he
played that con man or the uh,
the,
a convict in Australia.
The guy with the tattoos all over his
name or the cat tattoos all over his
body.
Damn it.
I've seen them in some really good
performances.
Hadn't the fuck up.
Remember that guy?
What's that guy's name?
Eric Bana.
What was the movie played?
It was like the movie that let everybody
know who the fuck he is.
Chopper.
That's a Chapa.
Russell Crowe had romper stomper use
that one.
He plays a skinhead watches for.
I was his first movie that kind of send
them off.
Um.
Anyway.
Yeah,
maintain his performance as Bruce
Banner.
Just fucking hamstringing them.
I watched it on pot brownies or cookies
or some form of edible and I'm just
like,
bullshit bullshit.
He was like,
so like phoning it in.
It's so fake.
There was some scene where the guy and
the girl are talking and it was so fake.
I was like,
ah,
I lost it.
I lost the trance of the movie because
we're not.
We can do that.
Like I think tons of what you can do
that too.
You can either dial you in so you get
things that no one would get or you can
all of a sudden see the costumes on the
actors.
That's nice.
Especially animals,
man.
They make you super sensitive to bad
acting,
but
if you go see like that fucking Daniel
Day Lewis movie,
what was the one where a drink?
My milkshake with the fuck was that.
There will be blood,
there will be blood.
Go see that one when your highest fuck,
it'll lock you in and you'd be like,
Jesus.
Imagine if you knew this fucking guy and
you actually had a deal with this guy.
We're gonna.
Have to kill this guy.
I drank a milkshake like,
fuck.
I don't remember any of that movie.
Remember as I'm swimming in like 40 feet
out in the Pacific,
there was a good fucking movie.
He finds out that his brother,
not his brother,
and he fucking take them back to the
beach and skill.
How about,
spoiler alert,
sorry guys.
Who Listen Christ you haven't fucking
watched.
If I know a lot of people that haven't
seen yet,
erase,
erase bad memories.
Race.
Yeah.
That guy is just.
He knows how to do it.
Like whatever it is that acting is.
That guy knows how to do it.
He's that guy.
Yeah.
Towns with New York's gangs in New York.
That was the first time I realized I was
like,
because I remember seeing the last of
the Mohicans when I was a kid and I was
like,
ah,
it's a good movie.
But I thought there'd be more action.
I didn't.
I couldn't appreciate acting or
whatever.
And then.
But when I saw games in New York,
I was like,
mother Fucker,
this guy is that guy.
Like he's.
He committed.
Yeah.
He's,
he's in the groove man.
And he does that with a bunch of
different characters too,
that I played that Ira guy who was a
boxer.
He was called the boxer,
right?
Yeah.
I think that was like the best
performance of an actor pretend to be a
boxer,
the most realistic because it looked
like real boxing,
whereas opposed to like a lot of these
movies,
like what a lot of people are missing is
the choreography.
It shows one guy teeing off on the other
guy and that's very rare.
In reality.
It's usually exchanges like you're
hitting each other,
like the good guy gets hit to you know,
but if you look at like,
like Marky mark's movie,
was that the,
the,
the boxer,
whatever the fuck it was.
What was his movie?
The fighter.
Yeah.
Apparently he's boxed before,
but those,
the choreography of the boxing scenes,
this is very unrealistic.
It didn't look anything like watching
Mickey Ward fight.
If you watch mickey ward fight mean he's
taking shots.
He had this like,
uh,
this ear muff style defense.
He kept his hands up high.
He would come in and he takes shots and
throw vicious body punches.
But you're marky mark.
His hands are down.
It's faces out there.
It's not like a real boxer.
Daniel Day Lewis,
look,
the guy had been punched in the face
like there's a difference between the
guy who gets punched in the face all the
time,
the way they hold their hands,
the way they're actually aware that
that's a possibility,
and then guys who just not thinking it
can get.
They can get hit at all.
If you're in a movie,
it's one thing if you're hitting the bag
or something,
but if you're in a movie,
you're playing boxer.
It's very important that you look like
someone who might get hit in the face
as opposed to an actor who knows what
the cameras
act,
who knows what the camera is and knows
how to throw the punches together,
but it's unrealistic because the guy's
not hitting you back like it doesn't
look like the guy can't hit you back.
You're not scared of the guy.
You're not posturing.
Like Daniel Day Lewis,
he's got his hands up,
he's moving,
he's throwing punches,
he's throwing his left hand.
His right hand is here.
When he throws his right hand,
his left hand's here at shoulders are
hunched.
He's not standing like some fucking
superhero.
He's standing like a boxer.
He's like making his target small.
His footwork is excellent.
The Way He's delivering the Jab,
right hand combination.
The one two combination looks very
smooth.
Everything looks real and he boxed for a
full year.
Before he did that role for a full year,
this motherfucker trained every day he
got up,
he went jogging.
He lived like a boxer.
He went to the gym,
he hit the mets,
he hit the speed bag,
hit the heavy bag.
He did rounds.
He put fucking vaseline on his face and
they.
They sent him out there with a cup on.
They beat the shit out of each other.
He did it for a year.
Do a year.
He lived like a pro boxer for a fucking
year and when that movie came around,
he really looked like a boxer.
What about,
did you see the movie warrior?
Which one's the one with the.
Unfortunately I did.
That one made me cry also.
That was a good move.
It was a good movie,
great movie.
It was poorly executed.
As far as money concerned.
It was preposterous.
First of all,
you would never make people fight two
days in a row.
It would never happen.
You can't do that because two days in a
row,
the first day you get beat the fuck up
everybody.
Even the people who win,
the next day you're sore as fuck.
Your body's all beat up.
Your head might be,
you might have internal swelling.
You don't know.
There's a lot of shit that goes on with
these guys after a serious emma,
so you could never do two fights in a
row where you're going to war like that.
It's just not happening because this is
not happening.
And the.
I think the,
the,
the premise could have been achieved
with a realistic scenario.
Like you could have people fight more
than one time at a night.
That's happened.
People have done that.
They barely limp into the final round
sometimes,
but people have done it.
People have fought three times in a
night that's happened.
You know they did it
in the,
in the.
That Horian Gracie hex hex or hoist
probably.
No,
no,
no.
The one that's in Hickson and that when
he fought twice in a month.
Yeah,
that was Japan valley too though.
about three times.
Three times.
Two or three times,
but three times is not uncommon.
Back then they used to have those
tournament.
They did that recently on glory man.
Joe Showing guy was in here a couple of
weeks ago.
He made it to the fucking finals man.
He fought three times in a night against
killer.
He's finding killers.
He fought this guy.
The first guy he fought was undefeated.
He fights him and then he fights another
guy who had beaten him and then he goes
to the finals and fights arguably the
best middleweight in the world,
so it was fucking ridiculous.
Man.
I have a hard time to.
A three show nights.
Yeah,
like I do that in Columbus sometimes.
I was there last week.
I was like,
no,
three show.
I can't do it.
I was like,
are those 30 show?
I'm literally going.
I get on stage.
I'm like,
I have no idea what I've said so far.
Yeah,
because you've done two shows already.
You're getting confused with your jokes.
Also,
the audience has done.
It's midnight.
Yeah,
it's the fucking 18 and under show.
Usually those ones and really that's
what they do it.
Well,
Miami,
Miami was 1800 was chaos.
Fucking God picks wagon chaos.
Like swaggy dude.
I know I've told you,
but he had a number of times were were
getting on the stage and showing their
dicks like and I was just like,
I made friends with the wrong gang and
they showed up on my show and they just
get on stage and show their dicks and it
was fucking chaos.
Made friends with them,
lol.
It was,
it was like,
it was like stepping shit.
Stupidity.
I was doing radio DJ labs in Miami.
He's like the biggest radio guy and
there was this gang called.
There was this band called the zoe pound
and I was like,
I'm doing radio with them and I bring in
Tequila and we're all drinking tequila
and they're allowed to talk about this
without getting good enough.
Of course,
of course.
Of course.
Yeah.
No,
I mean it was on radio.
Every everything was up and up and all
this was set on radio and so I just
started doing shots with them.
It's Kayla and the radio and with Tj
last and then I invited them to the show
that night and then halfway through the
song they were seeing was Amazon,
so Amazon,
so Amazon for life or whatever.
And I went,
you sang along with it.
I'm fucking,
I'm sure I was,
I was drunk but the uh,
halfway through I go,
wait.
So pat myself,
so familiar and literally
so you guys don't ganglion let's Dj
Aladdin
losing his mind,
like mother fucker.
And I had already invited him to the
show.
So then they came out with the show was
fucking chaos.
It was absolutely
djs asking you,
do you know what?
You're the one who got him in the
studio.
Motherfuckers are letting me know that
he's upset at you,
that you don't know who they are.
How about you telling me bitch was as a
secret?
But yeah,
it was.
So,
uh,
and then everyone came to my show that
night and I had to drink tequila on
stage and then next day a bunch of gang
members came on stage.
Whether Dixon was fun,
chaos,
heart,
or were they just,
they were soft and they were massive.
They were fucking massive.
They were heckling.
So fucking bad.
You have no idea.
And I can't,
I can't,
I don't know these three dudes,
I never met them other than I knew that
they were armed because that's what the
manager said.
The manager told you they were armed and
kick them out.
I could do it.
They were heckling so bad they had
leased credo.
They elected her so bad that she was
very visibly upset.
And then the guy goes on next feature
act and his hair is matt.
He's like Balding Guy,
a little bit like feathered covered.
But when it comes off it's matted sweaty
to his bald head and he's just fucking
like,
he's like,
are fucking assholes.
They're ruining the show.
And so I told the manager who's not
there for a long time now.
I said,
uh,
can you ask them to leave or tell them
to be quiet?
And he was like,
I think there armed.
I'm not gonna fucking say anything.
Say anything.
Yeah.
I think he just said,
you know,
take one on the Chin and here we go.
That's crazy.
These people just take over their club.
Uh,
yeah.
The possible potential threat of
violence.
They're letting these people just
dictate what goes on in their club.
They're letting these people believe,
believe the club around.
That's what's going on,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
but here's the deal.
Here's the deal.
I'd argue to say this,
that you probably hit up but her
differently,
but you're very different guy.
Me Or Bobby Kelly,
but like I feel like there's a New York
vibe and I just know how to deal with
that bad element where they're not
getting kicked out.
They've already paid.
They're going to be sitting here.
So I would just ask them questions that
I already had the answers to that were
set up to my jokes or bits I could get
into.
And then they were fine.
They don't want to just ruined the shot.
Sometimes people just want to ruin a
show to have a good time.
Yeah,
like all hecklers not created equal.
There's some,
some people heckled shit and it's,
it's funny.
I think.
I don't know.
I've,
I've dealt with a number of hecklers and
I had,
and I feel like starting in New York,
you can,
it's easy.
It's not easy,
but you just know how to fucking shut it
down.
Well,
you get used to being fucked with.
You know,
we were talking about that yesterday,
Brennan,
Brian,
Kaylin and I about actors,
like some actors who take themselves
super fucking seriously.
You can't joke around with them at all.
They'll just,
they'll,
they'll get fucking furious.
They have no sense of humor and they
storm off.
You know,
I think people who've been fucked with a
bunch,
you know what getting fucked with is
like you walk out,
they're like,
ah,
it's fucking bro.
What's up guys?
To get used to it,
you know,
like what?
Why are you guys giving me a hard time?
When did just accept the way I look.
I have body image issues already because
you're fucking,
oh,
it's my breasts.
You don't like my breasts,
okay,
well fuck you.
This is me.
You get on or get off the boat ride.
Okay,
I'm not changing.
This is who I am.
Like really self indulgent,
actory type thinking.
Well then you know,
you would have a hard time with
hecklers,
but if you're a guy that's like a guy
who did stand up at the store,
you know the store doesn't have any
crowd control.
So I started out there.
No one ever stopped anybody from young
shit out.
Very similar mentality.
Same as New York that would kick people
out though.
Shit get ugly.
They would kick people out.
They were just figuring out a way to do
it.
See I'm.
I am the opposite.
I'm the exact opposite of that in that
I'm maybe not perfect for hecklers,
but I want everyone to like me.
That's a massive fucking underlying tone
to my personality.
Even if they say something hurtful or
mean,
I don't snap on them,
it takes a lot for me to stop.
Well,
you should just as a craftsman,
not snap on them immediately anyway,
unless it's the funny thing to do and
you've got to know when it is.
It's like a weird sort of.
Sometimes it's funny to just snap on
someone right away and not as long as
you don't really mean it.
Like that's the thing too.
Like you can't actually be angry when
you snapping.
There has to be a smile there.
I mean like a real legitimate smile.
You have to be enjoying yourself and it
has to be that what you're doing is
you're putting on an improvised
performance,
dealing with these variables,
these people in the audience,
and if you can do that,
you can manage that.
You can make a like a,
a crazy situation become fun,
but it's like some people can't.
It's not their style.
Some people style is,
I prepared a performance and if you
heckled me,
you're ruining what I've prepared and
what I prepared is not better than
dealing with you and you're fucking up
for all these people around you and
they're right to man,
right?
Live performances or weird.
You can't control.
It's a crazy agreement that works most
of the time.
I mean,
it is a great testament to how fucking
cool people are that stand up works as
often as it does mean when everybody
looks shit like we're talking about the
news,
about how the news is always
highlighting all these negative things
because really what the news is an
entertainment show and the best way to
get you to be paying attention is to
scare you,
not to show you robust views of happy
people thriving in this world and being
loving and successful,
which is a great majority of people,
way more than just small.
That small percentage gets to the news
and so you look at the news like the
world's over run with cons,
but it's.
It's not,
it's not.
It's just that's what they're showing
you.
Like that's what's in front of you.
If you look at how many goddamn clearly
shows go on,
the great majority of people are fucking
amazing.
The great majority.
It's just a very few people that go one
out of 300,
maybe 600.
I like the thing that drives me more
nuts than heckling as those people who
talk to other people about something.
That's what drives me nuts as a table of
eight where a guy's talking across the
table and you've seen him leaning
forward,
knowing like,
hey,
let's say like don't mind heckling.
I feel like that's the way to.
My buddy was black from him saying that
racism is.
I'd rather know you're fucking racist
and know where my les than have you do
it behind my back then.
Then you're sneaky.
Yeah,
definitely.
You want to know if somebody who doesn't
like your son's going to be a problem.
So there's people that talk,
like just talk like shit.
I just fucking.
That will make me crazy and that'll
snap.
That'll be weird.
Yeah.
I've seen people talk like not why I've
been onstage,
but rather while other people,
but on stage I've seen people like like
talk shit about the comedians
performances like in the front row and
then I saw what Nick Depalo or
something,
Nick Depaulo,
some guy was like,
he had his arms crossed and nick,
even though nick was killing with the
rest of the crowd,
he's like this fucking guy with his arms
crossed like what's going on here?
Like what?
Yeah,
my job's not good enough for you.
Like became like this session with them.
His arms crossed,
the guy had his arms crossed but I've
seen people like talk shit about people
like this guy sucks like in the front
row and you see the color blue.
How's this guy going to do with the
comic deal with it?
Like oh I suck sir.
You know like you know what's going on
here?
And you always winds up being.
These people were way less clever than
they think they are.
They think they're going to get you.
And it's almost like,
like when someone throws a haymaker at
you and you just get out of the way of
it,
you're like,
what was that supposed to hit me?
And I'm like,
Oh shit,
now you know you're going to be in for a
long night because now you're actually
having a conversation with a stand up
instead of being able to say to your
friend of this guy sucks.
Now this guy's gonna focus on you to
trip up.
You're just kinda okay.
Unless you're some fucking comedy wizard
that's undercover,
that's,
you know Kay.
And even then you don't have a
microphone.
You're going to,
you're going to get beaten up by someone
who's a real comic.
They're gonna be able to chew you up.
But they don't think that.
They don't think that they think they're
smarter.
Like when people see people fight.
I can't tell you how many times where
people after UFC goes,
why the fuck didn't the guy just do
this?
Why does he just do it?
Why is he fucking hit them with the
right hand?
Like,
what are you talking about?
Think it's not an easy to punch somebody
like,
what are you crazy?
You don't think he sees the right hand
coming,
who's right in front of them.
Oh,
okay.
Why don't you go do it?
You don't know what you're talking
about.
Were trying to do this.
This is crazy talk.
When they.
If they actually got out there,
they would shit their pants and realize
like,
oh,
this is a moving target that's better at
this than me and they're moving faster
than I can move.
I'm going to get hit in the head.
Oh my God.
And then really thinking about getting a
hit in the head.
He try to throw a punch.
I.
Yeah.
That's reality.
Every time you throw a punch,
Bang,
you get your fucking head knocked back.
That that's reality.
When people are watching shit,
they're ridiculous.
Confidence plus booze.
They give this stupid distorted idea of
who they are in the greater spectrum
thing.
They think they're better at something
than you without even ever dealing it,
which is hilarious.
Amazing how fast a real life punch.
Like how you're right.
You can kind of do.
It's almost like a dance move in your
head versus the dance move.
You really do.
Like I've only done one punch and I
fucking.
When I did that cracked my nose on my
knee because I ducked way too fucking
hard.
I just went black and fucking was like,
Holy Shit.
But that's the reality of it is you go,
I know what to do by just have never
done the dance myself.
Well,
that's what that Daniel Day Lewis,
this
guy did a reason why he looks so good as
a boxer.
He was out there moving with real
boxers,
getting hit,
ducking,
bobbing and weaving so that when he was
in there,
he had a realistic sense of the
movements that you would actually be
performing while you're fighting as
opposed to like a lot of guys like,
yeah,
and then I might hit him with a punch.
He's going to go falling back to when
your face is wide open up bob and you're
not leaving.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's unrealistic sense of competence
without experience is the sign of a
fucking idiot.
And that's a really common thing,
especially with men.
Men with testosterone and alcohol
combined with very little,
few,
very few real live experiences as far as
like really having to pull yourself up,
really having to dig down deep and find
out what your character is all about.
There's a lot of guys going through life
that never find out who the fuck they
really are.
When the going gets rough,
they just don't know.
They've never been there,
so their idea of what they're capable of
or how they would respond to those
situations is based on fucking movies.
It's based on like hero bullshit movies.
You know the Guy Kicks Your Butt Jazz.
That's why I'm fucking door kick her
buddies.
I saw u two video,
I know what to do.
I'll kick this guy's ass.
Kicked the reality.
Those that's terrifying.
There's no rules.
So this is.
This is a wild like no one knows that's
going to happen here.
This is completely improvisational and
it involves violence and involves you
being successful at achieving violence
on someone who's probably been doing it
way longer than you know the way better
at you.
Just like a comic is way better at
cracking jokes and a person who's never
been on cracking jokes.
When you see actors play comics and
movies and you go,
oh,
that's,
you're clearly acting.
You were clearly are because you never
did stand up because I know right now,
but if there was a stand up to him that
he would simply be doing stand up and
they'd be filming it as opposed to
watching them act as if they're font.
Oh,
it's fucking painful and fucking sally
field.
I was just thinking one is awful.
Oh,
it's painful,
Lord.
Still fucking one with um,
there was no.
Yeah,
there was.
There's more that have been out like
that,
but we just watched someone who's
clearly not a standup in your life like
now.
And I think seth Rogan's very funny,
but he's not a stand up stand up.
Maybe he's not.
How dare you.
He's.
It was.
Have you ever seen this Canadian
performance he has on his first
performance in Canada?
Online.
You should watch it,
man.
It was a really funny.
I think he's hilarious in all his
movies.
I think he's an amazing writer.
An amazing actor.
I love watching the guy,
but just when I saw him in that movie,
I thought it was a great actress in it,
but we did stand up.
I thought he was doing a version of
someone else that people thought he
would be doing as opposed to seth rogen
the movies.
I watch the movies I watched when I
watched him be funny.
That is not him being funny like that,
that that's not the translation of that.
You know?
Another problem is what when they have
those movies were guys who stand up on
stage.
The materials never good,
right?
You know why you're never going to give
you good material that you could use
their fucking movie.
Fuck you.
If I come up with a.
If I'm writing for a movie about stand
up and I come up with a really good
idea,
I'm not going in that Muslim village
that's going over here.
I'm going to store that.
I'm going to give you some mediocre
nonsense that you could add.
I always think that about writers for
like a productivity shows that started
up stand up.
So I'm like,
there's no way I couldn't.
I could never,
I'd never write for anybody.
I can never write for anybody that can
never,
that's not me.
I could never take material from other
people.
I need to.
It all needs to be mine.
It needs to come from you entirely.
100%.
And it needs to be my words.
Some guys can't do that.
They don't have the time,
you know,
they're doing a bunch of movies and so
they just don't.
They're terrible writers.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with hiring writers,
if that's what you want to do.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I don't do it.
Um,
most of my friends don't do it.
I don't know anybody who does it.
I know a guy who does it,
but I don't know him personally,
but it's fine.
I mean,
it's,
it's a,
uh,
an honest exchange.
I don't know when Larry the cable guy
doing it or Jeff Foxworthy,
your bill angle.
I just think anyone who's not a
household name in that respect,
uh,
just thought I just fucking tap out.
1996.
Seth rogen doing standup comedy in
Canada.
Wow.
Yeah.
No,
he's a comic.
I heard him on me.
The company talking about it.
He definitely started out as a colleague
county in a movie.
Again,
he's probably not doing stand up right
now under.
I think he did a little bit for that
movie to prepare for it,
but he's not doing it enough to where
he's got like 20 killer minutes that he
could do in the movie and they give him
some whack ass material.
The good stuff going to use on stage,
you're going to use it for a special.
You're going to use it like if you're a
comic especially,
and the guys who were good comics are
the guys who are going to be good at
writing standup comedy.
If someone's never done standup comedy,
it's just theoretical.
Whether or not their jokes are good.
There's a lot of people that write for
sitcoms that have never done stand up
and never performed,
and they have some ideas what they think
will be funny in a scene and
occasionally there.
Right.
Occasionally.
But they're wrong is almost as much as
they're right.
You know,
unless they're really good writers,
you know,
on a really good show with we've got a
tremendous amount experience.
They've got a good feel of the dynamic
of these situations and what's going to
be funny about the pause and what can be
funny about this line in response to the
pause,
but a lot of them are just guessing,
guessing like you'll get scripts.
Dude,
I've read some scripts I've read.
I've read a script recently where I'm
like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Realize none of this is funny that my go
on page after page.
Like when does it get to be funny?
You fucking lazy concept like this.
This is shit.
This is like shit writing.
But that's a lot of it out there man.
Go Watch an episode of fucking two and a
half men.
Charlie Sheen left Jesus Christ though
you'll have a heart attack.
Who were the jocks?
Why don't you just.
What are you trying to make me watch it
when he was still on the show,
same shit sometimes.
Sometimes they lose half decent
of funny,
you know,
half decent premises.
That kid,
the kid,
uh,
passed away.
Harold Harris whittles.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
he,
I read that some of his writings from
Aziz Ansari wrote a blog about him.
The kid,
his writings were fucking hilarious.
Shit.
That's all.
I think I met him one time in Houston a
long time ago.
We worked the door,
but who he is,
that's fun.
It's really hard to translate even being
funny on stage to writing a script and
making it funny.
Really fucking hard.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard to get a real genuine sense of
interaction between two human beings
when you're trying to put in punch
lines.
Oh God.
Some people are so bad at it.
I got fucking really spoiled because the
writers on news radio were really good
to have no idea how to play that show us
no.
Just as an outside wall.
Someone who watches it,
like you have no idea.
Like because you had to deal with Andy
Dick every day.
It was all right.
No,
but I mean like even just working with
them,
like on the,
from the outside looking in and Dick was
so goddamn hilarious on that show.
It's a real tragedy that,
that character,
that,
that didn't turn him into fucking what
Ben Stiller is,
you know,
it's just crazy.
No,
I mean he got the Andy Dick show and all
the other stuff and you know,
Andy will tell you himself that it was
more battling demons and anything.
He's got a lot of demons thing that he's
talking about on his instagram the other
day I looked at it and it was a him
drinking some healthy drink.
He's like,
thank God I'm addicted to something
healthy for once.
You know?
I mean that's his,
his,
his deal.
It just is always going to be as deal.
But we used to do scenes.
We had to do it like three or four times
because I couldn't fucking not laugh.
Oh really?
Break,
break.
Because he drove me nuts on this set.
Right.
Sometimes.
Sometimes it was great.
I mean,
out of all the times we worked together,
he didn't drive me nuts the majority of
the time.
It wasn't that bad.
He,
he became way more out of control after
he left the show that he was on the
show,
like really getting arrested and all
that stuff.
That didn't go on while I was on the
show.
The.
Did you guys have a set of.
I don't think I've ever asked you this.
Did you have a set next door to
Geraldo's?
Yes.
That.
Did you guys use to drink beers after
or?
We would go to a while.
We just drink beer on the set.
We drink beer.
I'm down the street.
There was this bar that we used to go to
that would be like a lot of different
shows would go there.
I hung out with the dude from A.
Everybody loves Raymond.
The old man.
What's The guy's dad?
A famous actor to fast,
so no.
Oh Fuck Peter.
Yes.
Not O'toole.
Peter.
He was in young Frankenstein oil.
Poured a Peter Boyle.
Yeah.
Peter Boyle.
Yeah,
he was in young Frankenstein.
He was in a bunch of movies,
has been around a long time.
He was cool as fuck.
We got to hang out with a lot of cool
people back there.
I was wanting to party with the girl
that was on your show.
Which one?
Melissa?
The hearing I remember.
I think I heard for Geraldo say she was
just fun to party with.
She liked to drink.
Yeah,
she likes to get fucked up,
but she's hilarious too.
She's very funny.
She's a really good actress,
actor,
whatever you want to call it.
She's so good that sometimes we'd be
doing scenes and I wouldn't really know
that we started doing the scene.
I'd be.
I thought she was just talking because
you know,
like she was like so natural the way she
would act as it was really natural,
kind of creepy.
Like it'd be like woo,
but it's like that's the craft,
the craft of like sliding effortlessly
into a role with no bullshit about it
and that's something that's very hard
for a lot of people to do and it's very
hard for a lot of people to write that
way as well.
That's the big thing.
Like you've got to,
for an actor,
like you get a great actor,
like a Stephen Root,
like Stephen Root,
like never.
He didn't really add Lib.
They would write,
he had a very specific,
very um,
like clear character Jimmy James.
So he's not anything like that guy.
He met him.
No,
I think the biggest sweetheart,
he's like,
you know,
Jimmy James,
the boss is like the slick talking guy
and you know,
it was kind of like,
not dumb but not really interested in
like he was here.
Yeah.
Dude,
that show was,
I mean I show was honestly,
and I know you guys always teetered on
whether or not you're going to get
renewed.
That shows one of my favorite shows I've
ever seen ever on television.
Quantum leap number one,
that shone number two.
I mean like,
Hey,
we're in love.
The company got moved nine times.
News radio moved nine times before the
Internet,
so there was no internet back then,
whether it was in internet.
I guess the Internet sort of started in
1994,
but nobody was using it to find out what
time shows were on.
The amount of people that were on the
Internet back then was fucking nil.
I mean it was just.
Yeah,
it was during Dialup,
it was during 14,
four,
but dialogue,
that's when it started fucking 14 form
baud modems when everything was slow as
fuck.
If you want to download a picture of
tits,
it would be like chunk,
chunk,
and also start off now.
And then it's a dick.
This will be loaded by the time I come,
but they get past her tits and she's,
she's jerking off.
She's Kinda tick the um,
but the show moved nine different times.
So it'd because you guys weren't like a
definite hit.
Does that mean you guys,
I feel like when it hits,
it brings the cast closer together.
I don't know.
I mean we definitely couldn't get a big
head,
which is good because there's a lot of
people that get big heads when they get
successful.
There's no way around.
It happens.
So often.
We're talking about the other day about
this,
uh,
this show where this guy got on it and
then immediately start acting like a
cunt.
Like just thought he was.
Every reality show the whole world
revolved around.
It wasn't a reality,
shows us,
the whole world revolved around them and
they wanted to fucking ruining his
entire career,
but that just happens when things get
successful.
Something happens when certain people
get successful when especially like
actors and there's all a part of them
that almost like serial killers want to
get caught.
This is a part of actors where they're
act.
They act so ridiculous that they almost
want someone to call them on it.
Like they,
they,
they almost want someone to tell them,
hey,
you're being a fucking cunt.
And they're like,
yeah,
you know,
ever clearly was like,
there's a comedy movie that my friend
did with this guy and the guy's a famous
guy and in the middle of the scene he
just starts smashing this car.
He can't.
He fucked up.
So he starts kicking at his car and he
breaks the windows and he breaks his
side mirror off and you just fucking
picks up something and smashes it
against his car.
Fucks his car up and,
and I don't know it was somebody's car
over his productions car or what is.
But he felt like he was such a big deal.
He's a very famous guy that at the time
he just felt like he gets smashed this
car.
So just smashed the car on set.
Yeah,
I mean it's just one of those things.
It's like he kind of went crazy like he
but he went crazy because he could get
away with it.
They cleaned it all up and he paid for
whatever the damage was in the car and
that's where it ended.
And it's like,
it's,
it's one of those things.
It's like,
you can't do that if you're in the
teamsters,
you can't do the craft service guy.
The craft service guy can't say,
look,
I'm going to pay for that car.
I fucked it up.
Like,
no,
you're not going to pay for.
You're going to go to jail.
You asshole.
Yeah.
Eventually you'll pay for it.
Even if you do pay for it,
fuck you.
You don't work here anymore.
I don't care how good your egg
sandwiches.
You can't smash someone's car because
you fucking burnt and egg.
But if you're an actor,
you can get this sense that it's okay
for you to just smash this fucking car.
Like that kind of makes people go nutty
when they get famous.
When things go really well for them.
We never got famous.
We never went well.
We were on television and it was like
really hard for people to just enjoy the
moment of being on television.
Like there was a lot of conversations we
had on the show.
We're like a balanced perspective was
required because they will be like,
I can't believe this show is after
friends.
This is bullshit that show fucking
socks.
And why are they after Seinfeld that
show fucking socks and why can't we be
on Thursday nights?
And you know,
God,
this is so frustrating.
And you know,
I remember we were having this
conversation.
I was like,
well last time I checked we're on
fucking TV.
We have a TV show,
you know,
and it's still in the year.
We're in like season three.
Like this is crazy.
Well,
there's probably no perspective at the
time that you guys were getting to work
with Phil Hartman.
Who is.
It was like a blessing.
It was definitely a perspective in that
that,
you know,
we definitely,
I definitely recognize Phil and Dave
Foley equally important.
Dave Foley was the glue that kept that
whole.
He was like,
what?
I see that guy slot producer.
I see that guy running that Kyle,
you run into him a wink,
what?
Our kids go to the same school,
but I always want to stop them and I
always want to stop him and say like,
it's.
I'm never good at meeting celebrities.
So I was like,
sweetie,
I want to go like,
hey,
I know Joe Rogan and,
but,
and are just do it.
I know you have a great conversation
with them.
Trust me.
He's a,
he's a sweetheart of a guy or he'd be
creeped out.
Like I have creeped out a lot of
celebrities before.
I think he would deal with it.
He's very intelligent.
No,
maybe I'll start to say how good dude,
man,
he's a really good dude and he struggled
with that fucking demon in a bottle to
you saying,
I didn't mean to interrupt you.
I'm sorry.
Do you remember who you were saying
that?
Uh,
I said Phil Hartman is so talented and
he was taken away so quick that you
didn't know you were getting to work
with like a fuck a guy that's a legend
at the end of his life.
We didn't,
we certainly didn't know it was the end
of his life,
but we definitely knew he was something
special.
You know,
he,
every time we went anywhere,
like that's where the people,
they didn't want her to talk to Phil,
like very rarely anybody wanted to talk
to me.
Like if they did interviews and stuff
like that,
I may occasionally people want her to
talk to me,
but most of the time it was,
they wanted to talk to Phil.
It was Phil fucking Hartman.
He was always doing big movies,
you know,
like he had that Sergeant Bilko movie
that turn out to be like a bomb that
while we're all together and he did
another couple of movies while we're all
together.
He was always,
he was always kicking ass.
He was always doing.
Was He in Beethoven?
I think he was the dad in Beethoven.
I like the third house.
I think it was in the third one.
Really.
There's those Groden who became a talk
show host.
Right.
Charles Grodin was in the first one and
I think down the line he got weird.
I think I got weird.
I think he just got implants or
something.
I think I just saw him with hair really
well.
He had wigs forever.
Maybe that's how I'm thinking of.
He might have.
He might have done it all up and then
release the hounds.
He seemed like an interesting guy.
He seemed like an interesting guy when
he's a comic and I think you'd fall off
the deep end.
Dudes get older and they just get tired
of it too.
The guy was around the 70s by the time
you know the year 2015 rolls around.
He's probably like,
I'm done.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not going to be me.
It's not.
No.
What are you going to do?
Joan Rivers it burn out.
No,
I was thinking.
I don't think he died.
I've been thinking about this lately.
I don't think you'd die.
You don't think you die?
I don't think you're done.
Good luck with that idea.
You probe it theoretically.
I guess it just ends up.
I just feel like there's.
I don't feel like you keep keep going
into new parallel universes.
It's just as possible.
The idea of could have done a lot.
You buy half,
you know,
and like,
yeah,
I might have died a million people die
around you.
What?
What's that about?
I think that's part of my university,
but it's not part of theirs and my own
parallel universe.
They die and that is for my journey for
them to die.
I remember last year,
dude,
we lost a bunch of guys.
I've lost a ton of friends from suicide,
but.
Oh well hold on.
Let's not even get into it.
We lost like foreign college and our
fraternity.
Yeah.
Three and three.
Your friends in high school committed
suicide?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
we lost it.
We lost somebody in our,
in our fraternity that at one point,
oh,
the therapist came in.
It's like you guys may not be being good
friends to each other because you guys
are killing each other.
Like it was like one or two year span,
the therapist blamed this on a therapist
to talk about,
to explain loss.
So at a certain point,
I feel like the second suicide,
I think by two years for suicides,
two years,
three years maybe.
Yeah.
So more than one a year.
We had one in the spring and one in the
summer.
And then uh,
and then we,
you know,
and so we brought a therapist in because
we're like,
all right,
is there,
is there something going on in this
room?
We're all killing ourselves.
Did a lot sexier than just a bunch of
fucking homophobic.
Dick's alcoholics,
homophobic,
racist,
depression.
And then we blow their brains out.
Drug problems.
Had no barriers.
How are these guys?
Iceland themselves?
Um,
but two guns,
one drugs when hanging.
There was a dude who was one of the
writers on news radio was a good friend.
He's a really good guy.
I really enjoyed talking to him.
He was a comic before the news radio
days.
His name is drake.
Say either.
It was a funny comic he'd been on and I
know that name.
He was a writer on news radio and he
wrote this thing,
if you ever see that video of me is like
the vh one fashion awards from 1997.
I played this crazy photographer that
didn't know anything about photography
photography to get laid.
He show your bike.
I was naked.
I was naked in front of this model like
a I.
The question was,
I say,
uh,
do you have any problem with,
am I going over her portfolio?
I'm like,
you're very beautiful.
This is excellent stuff.
Do you have any with.
She goes,
no,
I don't.
Next picture is me naked
taking a picture of something fatality
that fashion for these testimonies.
It was so funny.
It was written by drink.
Yeah.
And dre kill himself.
And um,
Lucy at Texas comic.
Um,
he was a Boston comic.
Well,
I don't know where he started,
but he,
I met him in Boston way back in the day.
Um,
he might've been from Texas originally,
but he was,
he started when I was in 1988 when I was
starting out.
He was in Boston.
He was doing stand up there and he was
more established than me.
He was like a couple of years ahead of
me and uh,
somewhere along the line he stopped
doing stand up and he had a family and
the whole deal.
And one day I don't know what happened,
man,
some breakup and I don't know,
I don't know what happened,
but he killed himself while he was on
the phone apparently.
But this wife and I that fuck me up and
that one fuck me up.
That was hard to take because I had been
over their house.
They had a party and I cut to meet
everybody and it was fun.
It was Harland Williams was there,
so I associated that party and being
over their houses like this is fun
friendly time and just to think that
that guy could go from that moment where
we're drinking wine and everyone's
laughing and you know,
it's having good times and good friends
and then so dark that he wants to end
it.
So,
so fucking funny too man.
Such a good writer.
Such a clever guy that this guy could be
so haunted that the lows were too low,
that he was like,
I can't do this.
I can't,
I can't cope with this frequency.
And he just,
boom.
Ari was the almost there,
you know,
a few years ago,
and now it's,
I was talking to him about this the
other day,
how he's changed.
So he has a billboard in front of his
old apartment now of his own face
podcasts about it,
but already was,
yeah,
he was very,
very down,
very down.
And uh,
a lot of it was like physical.
A lot of it was career related.
He thinks a lot of it might have had to
do with him taking propecia some and
some people,
propecia causes depression because dee
propecia,
the way,
if you read the literature on how it,
what does it inhibits?
Dihydrotestosterone,
which is d,
h d,
which is,
you know,
just essential part of being a human
being.
But that dht is what causes your hair to
fall out.
And it affects people in different ways.
Some people,
it kills their boners me killed my
boilers.
And uh,
I didn't realize until I got off of it,
I ran out of it and also my Dick was
hard as a rock.
I was like,
what is going on to help tear your hair
though?
Yes,
yes.
It keeps your hair.
And as soon as I got off of it and as
soon as I got off Rogaine to decided to
shave my head,
I bailed on everything because I was
losing the battle anyway.
And I was like,
I am going to have to abandon this
fucking dam and run from the river
because like,
I can't hold it back anymore like this,
a bit of Rogaine for like
fucking 22 years.
It holds onto your hands onto your head.
But as soon as you get off of that shit
folk who have like fire through bushes
baby.
Like if I grew my hair out now like,
oh my God,
dude,
your bullets.
Fuck.
Like for three years I've been shaved my
head and I had the exact same hair loss
when I met you.
You both use the sprinkle stuff and the,
um,
the uh,
propecia and the,
um,
what's the other stuff?
Oh,
I found this stuff that you get online
that was this,
um,
this a pump that was,
it was like as lead acid and retin a and
minoxidil and this company had the shit.
This was the shit stuff kept your hair,
but for whatever reason it wasn't
approved by the FDA.
So the FDA came along and they shut them
down.
But like I knew a bunch of dudes that
were taking this stuff.
It had retina and it would make your
hair red,
like your scalp read if you spray too
much of it in.
But the effect was pretty dramatic.
Like it really kept all of your hair and
when that stuff went away I took a hit.
When I got off probation I took a big
hit.
You could see like if you watch like
episodes of the UFC,
you could see like we started seeing
hair like light through my hair.
It's like it's going baby.
And then finally I had to let it go,
but I should've let it go a long time
ago.
I love having a shaved head.
It's foolish.
You could do it right now.
So hold on,
Joe.
Hope,
fuck,
I'll help you.
I'll tell you what.
I'll do anyone tennis to Rogaine.
I will do $1 million commercial.
Like let me give you $1 million to keep
my head for a million.
Like you're holding them hostage.
No,
I'll do the opposite.
Is that old time lapse?
Stop using Rogaine and just watch my
hair fall out.
And then you said all these young kids
who you want to keep your hair get on
this shit right now because I'm 42.
I should arguably be bald as fuck right
now.
I've been holding on his hair just with
the Rogaine my entire.
Since I was 22 I said this weekend,
tell me if you agree with this,
but it's a little bit of a stretch with
thought.
Men who lose their hair at a young age
that you start losing your hair.
That is the first record.
The first signpost for mortality in a
person.
Like you witnessed your mortality at a
young age when you realize,
fuck,
I'm actually losing my hair.
See?
Mortality.
To me it seemed more like,
like you couldn't control something like
[inaudible],
like going away from you and it's
something that makes you look better.
It was really confusing for a lot of
men.
It's very confusing and it freaked me
out.
Bad.
It was just shave your head.
That's the beautiful thing about it.
Like the solution of shaving your head
is always there and once you do it you
go,
Oh yeah,
why am I.
What am I going to here for?
I may shave it and then stay on Rogaine
or wish I shaved it when I was in my
twenties instead of going through hair
transplants,
all that stupid shit.
I have just shaved it.
Definitely do that again.
IfW ,
if I went back,
I would definitely do that differently.
No.
If they said that there was a pill that
could grow a full,
a full 18 year old head of hair for you.
I don't want any more here.
I'm good.
Yeah.
Like now I will.
The fuck
knows what else that pill's going to do
to you.
Like if I just shaved my head,
I'm a fairly happy with it.
Look,
I could be born in Ethiopia,
you know,
I could have been an Eskimo.
Not there's anything wrong.
All due respect.
I really think you're supposed to say
this shit out in an Igloo.
Some guy trying to get a walrus.
Vagina fence.
PILBARA had red hair.
There's a lot of things it could've been
way worse,
but like kind of deal with the hand
you've been given.
You ain't going to change it and take
that hand and fucking run with it man.
And sometimes the hand looks just
devastating.
Sometimes you got to fucking tools and
you're like,
this is it.
You've got A.
I got a two and a three.
Fuck,
this is nothing.
His hands dog shit.
And then you're going down the street to
the guy who was a soap opera.
Fabio looking motherfucker with the long
hair.
Like this guy's got all the fucking car
cut 52 deck card.
I got two cards is amazing.
I use that.
And people sometimes you go,
God,
that guy's got fucking everything.
I realized I got fucking nothing.
Well that's not true though.
You know,
it's like the thing about human beings,
it's like,
what?
What?
What are you?
You're not just how you look.
The problem is with a lot of people,
you gauge how you look based on how
sexually desirable you are.
That's the real issue with people.
You see it with a lot of people as they
get older,
they start freaking out and there's
fucking photos of Mickey rourke now make
your work much at the UFC this weekend.
It's like somebody talked to that guy.
He's.
He's got fake hair and fake lips in his
face.
Something's going on with his face and
it's like,
God,
give him a hug.
You know he's fucking Mickey Rourke.
Does he know he's Mickey Rourke?
Does he think it looks amazing?
I was mad at this.
I would love to drink with Mickey
Rourke.
She's just crying.
Nothing about old boxing stories for the
first.
First of our two,
he's fighting fake boxing matches.
You see he called.
He's 62 years old.
He thought some kind of boxing.
I just think it's total dive.
The guy never punched him in the face.
Once he hit the guy with a weak punch,
that body and the guy went down like he
was like,
someone stole his liver.
It was ridiculous.
It was so dumb.
It's so pathetic like you look,
this is the guy from nine and a half
weeks.
This is the guy from angel heart.
This is Mickey motherfucking rourke.
Every designer.
Is there anything about you that you
don't like that you'd like to change
now,
but for bonds,
man,
you deal with all the prospective deal
with the perspective of who you are in
comparison to who you could've been born
in Ethiopia with no feet.
Your renewals to off the top of them are
new.
The corn weird right here was just
smooth that out to be good.
You're not going to be good.
You can start tweaking it by other
things.
There's people that get their shins
broken and separated slowly with these
devices that make them inches taller.
In China,
it's a big deal.
There's a lot of guys in China that they
feel like they can't get a woman because
they're below five feet tall and so
there is slowly but surely stretching
the fucking bones of their legs have
these bolts that are attached to their
bone and they crank it and they slowly
separate.
They saw it and then they slowly
separated so it grows a little bit and
then they separate it more and it grows
a little bit and they separate it more
and the bone keeps filling in this
fucking madness.
The mechanics of your body are all out
of whack because you've got a seven foot
long shinbone like the whole thing is
madness.
People are crazy.
I think health and well being is good.
Maintaining vitality is good,
but he got also have perspective.
Perspective is big and sometimes people
they just get mad because they don't
look like Lorenzo Lamas in his prime.
They get mad because they're boring.
You know,
fill in the blank.
I wish I was Filipino and I'm tired.
We show was black and I'm Asian.
I wish I was Asian and I'm fucking
Portuguese.
People have weird things in their head
where they they,
they want to be something other than
what they are and right now that's
unavailable.
So you're,
you're losing resources in your 90
whatever the fuck it is.
Your ride on this globe.
You have a 90 year ride,
allegedly also the crusher.
We just die and don't.
You keep going and everybody else thinks
you're dead,
but you're on another plane of
existence,
which is possible to get together and
write a book.
That'd be awesome.
That'd be fucking working.
We're team white.
Gold,
right?
What does that mean to you?
Awesome article about you.
Is that what you're talking about?
No,
I'm talking about the dress that's on an
article that I haven't make me think
about you as a about the white city.
The monkey monkey.
God had just found out and I saw it and
I thought I saw the thing and it looks
like your shirt at yours.
So I tweeted it.
That's uh,
that's crazy.
Crazy
man.
They found this hidden city in Honduras
that was legendary up until recently,
and they haven't even disclosed its
origin,
but they brought back artifacts like
this motherfucker's real like we've
found a hidden city in Honduras from a
long time ago where it's gone.
There's nothing but relics and shit.
I just think that's so fucking cool.
It's so cool that they.
They keep finding shit like that in the
Amazon too.
They have these satellite images and
they go away.
What is that?
Look at this shape of this.
This is symmetrical.
Then they realize like,
oh my God,
it's a canal system.
Oh my God,
this is a fake.
So fucking city.
They got swallowed by the jungle.
They have hills that they thought it was
just a hill and they realize it's a
building.
Like there's some structure underneath
this hill and the.
The dirt literally grew over it and
trees grew on the dirt.
So there's this mound in the middle of
nowhere and you walk up to it.
You're like,
what's going on here?
And archeologists start digging.
Then they go,
oh,
this is a fucking building man.
Like Shit.
Well,
there's,
there's a type of,
I think it's called a total tax that
they don't even exactly know what they
looked like.
They don't know where they came from.
They had very African looking faces and
they live something thousands and
thousands of years ago down in Mexico
and South America and like were like,
okay,
who the fuck are these people like they
don't know.
They have giant heads.
Have you ever seen those toll tag cans?
Jamie?
Pull up an image of one of the toll tech
heads.
They find these enormous blocks of stone
that are cut out to the shape of these.
These African faces heads.
Real weird man.
There's one over there.
I think there's no one over there.
They don't exist in the world of the
travel channel.
Jesus lems one other kind of heads.
TOLTEC head.
Look at that.
That's an African looking face,
man.
You're talking about the Easter island.
Okay.
That's a different place.
This is in Central America,
man.
They find these fucking things like 600
tons or something crazy.
How big are those fuckers,
Jamie?
Google how big those heads are,
but I might have made up that weight,
but look what they look like.
They're fucking cool as shit that looks
like an African.
The Lips.
Yeah.
Some of them are tossed over.
Some of them are.
Uh,
some of them are.
Um,
they're all different sizes and shapes.
Joe,
you never,
I saw you tweet you.
You just didn't even get into the whole
dress thing that happened the other day.
The way cold blue,
black thing.
Don't give a fuck about dresses.
No,
no,
no.
But do you understand what happened?
Course.
It's grown,
man.
Don't you think that's interesting?
We could both look at the same picture
and see two different colors,
but why is that a explained as the run?
Supposedly it's the cones and people's
eyes.
Like my,
my eyes are more open circles.
That's what the eye doctor used to
always tell me.
He was like,
you have more of an eye was going by,
but it's,
I guess how the shape of your cones and
how you get light,
but how come it looks?
It's different to different people.
Like sometimes it looks different to the
same person,
you'll get one image,
golden cross blue,
mine will look like white and gold,
and then like an hour later I look at it
and be like,
it's a completely different picture and
I would freak out.
I'm like,
where's the picture I was just looking
at?
And then,
uh,
so I can switch back and forth where I
know people that can't switch or people
that only see blue and black,
white or gold.
No,
that's nothing compared to what Phil
plait made for slate.
Um,
pull up a phil plait.
Slate magazine.
Um,
slate online.
I'm a color.
What would you say?
Color confusion.
Color illusion.
Optical illusion.
Color.
Optical.
Illusion.
That's what you also pull up the dress.
Look at this.
Look at this one.
This is way crazier.
You see those blues and those Greens?
That's the same color.
The exact same color.
Yes it is.
When you look at it in photoshop,
you realize it's the exact same color.
It's the green.
Scroll back,
Jamie,
scroll down.
When you look at it,
the green has the orange go through it.
But the blue doesn't,
the blue,
the orange turns into purple.
That confuses your eyes.
You got closer
to the exact same color at Jamie.
Do you have the picture of the dress
though?
Uh,
just to see what I want to see what you
guys actually see on the dress.
You see how it is when you get it close
up.
That green is across the board.
I mean how trippy is that?
Burnt Perc can't deal.
And he's freaking out.
What's weird about the dresses that
people were saying?
It's blue and black and I put it into
photoshop.
I mean I spent like three hours on this.
Me and Asa Akira or going back and forth
like how we're like,
we're going to start our own communion
somewhere and don't trust blue and black
people and stuff.
But I took it right now I see white and
gold.
Whoa.
You guys are both retarded.
Do you have the dress was blue and black
and blue and black.
Joe.
That's white and gold.
You got an issue with your brain,
right?
Am I right?
Jamie?
See the two sensible people
see blue,
black,
blue and black.
Blue.
And black dress,
you're,
you're refusing to acknowledge that.
Jamie,
you're completely missing the point
here.
The actual dress was blue and black.
I actually have it on my phone.
This is what you're seeing right now.
This,
this is not what you stumble.
He's getting very.
No,
this is not what I see right now either.
But this is what they're saying.
This is a,
the act that was the actual dress that
they have.
Um,
but th,
th,
th.
Well it's a light blue,
so very,
very light blue.
But there's no point in the gold is
like,
like the black is like a gold for sure.
No,
no,
that does not look black.
No,
I see white and gold.
I see white and gold right there.
Well it's not white because if you look
at the white beside,
the reason why he can make out the
outline is because beside it is an
absence of light,
which we think of as white.
No,
no.
Jump.
But if you look at that,
you would say,
hey,
that's a white and gold dress.
But in a shadow or something like kind
of annoying.
No,
I would say it's a light blue and a
almost like a brownish gold is dark
gold.
So you're seeing white and gold.
You're not seeing this.
Oh No,
I'm seeing light blue.
I'm seeing blue.
I'm seeing blue and I'm seeing this.
Gold is like a like a dark gold,
almost like a milestone.
Mustard.
It's darker than muster.
It's darker than most of you are
actually seeing what people are saying
as the white and gold.
No,
but yeah,
but it's definitely blue sky blue and
the blues.
Difficult to discipline,
right.
You're not seeing this,
so you actually are seeing what me and
Bert are seeing in Jamie's saying this.
Is that what you're seeing,
Jamie?
No,
I don't see this is.
This is a goofy argument because the
contrast is very different like which
you're looking at there.
The contrast between that color and the
white behind it is very different than
when you're looking at there that
there's.
This is a different image and because
it's different image shot in different
light.
You have a different perspective.
No,
no.
What I'm saying is though there's two
different ways people are seeing it.
You're seeing it,
the white and what they're saying
is the white and gold,
so hundred percent because I could see
both gets white.
You know,
I see both.
I see white and gold right now.
See anything other than white and blue
to you?
Not at all.
Not in the slightest.
No.
Can we cut to the chase and why is it
that I see this?
It's because of the how your eye is
shaped and the cones and how your eyes
precipitate colors and stuff like that.
You will can actually wear whatever
color.
Yeah,
proceed.
Received a love Brian.
Super simple change.
It's just how you're pretty much easy
way as how your eyes take shadows and
your brain goes,
all right,
that shadow is purple or blue,
but you can watch.
If you look at this,
I keep it on my phone.
If you look at it like once an hour,
it will change throughout the day.
Obviously will see what golden should
those,
but here's the thing that makes it more
important.
Show is what else are you seeing
different than that person?
Like like if I'm looking at a face,
I'm seeing this face,
that's beautiful and that person's
seeing a guy,
you know,
like some people are color blind,
man.
I'll tell you what,
that some people don't see certain
colors.
I'll see.
I was.
I thought you were talking about.
Nevermind.
I was on the.
I think socially I see things that other
people don't see it today.
I was jogging in the park next to our
house and these two girls cop pulls up,
parks pulls these two girls that are
sitting at the young ladies were sitting
on a park bench to interrogate some of
the purses,
cuffs to them and I'm watching this.
I'm jogging around the park cuffs to
them and put stars to put them in the
back of the car,
but as he cuffs them,
they kind of one in first.
Then the other next and I saw that the
two girls clearly in high school,
I'm going to say 10th grade and 11th
grade,
that they weren't crying and I didn't
see that as how sad I saw that as
someone needs to step in and fix these
girls because if they've gotten
handcuffed and thrown in the back of the
car and they're not crying,
then there's something wrong with this
picture.
There's clearly something wrong.
These girls need a life lesson changed
them because you.
If you cuffed me in 10th grade,
I probably would've started tearing up
and freaking out and they just come to
me and then this guy that was smoking a
cigarette,
walking his dog and now I'm trying to.
I got my head buds out so I'm trying to
hear what the cop saying.
We're walking right by him.
He said,
how sad,
how sad I went.
I was like,
no,
these,
these little girls have a problem,
but that's so true in the way you see
social,
like social things you'll see
differently tonight.
I don't know if it has to do with the
way you're brought up or the things that
have gone through your life,
but the black and blue dress,
you know,
here's.
Here's the interesting way to show that
we're all looking at the dress the wrong
way.
If you take the picture of the dress on
your laptop,
go into your preferences and invert your
screens.
What it does is it reverses the colors.
It stays exactly the same.
If you see it white and gold,
it's not supposed to stay the same.
Obviously it's supposed to change to a
different color.
So yeah,
it's tricky.
It's a trip.
I made a video.
I,
if you look on my instagram,
where I it,
where I reversed
my colors on my computer and it stays
exactly the same.
If you go to instagram.com/red
band,
fascinating job.
You could pull that out.
It's pretty cool.
So truth is a weird thing.
It's very weird.
We just guessed that we're seeing the
same thing,
but there's some dudes that are into
like really weird checks,
you know when you go,
what does that guy saying?
My,
my,
my overall three on this whole thing now
is that time travel was created that day
because it,
that day started off the llamas,
the black and white Lama it.
Do you remember that?
There was a police chase in Arizona and
it was seriously everybody was talking
about on twitter,
every chance TV channels was on tv and
it was just a police chase of trying to
capture a black and white Lama and they
ended up capturing the,
the blue,
the white lama or something like that.
The black line,
but it was like a race thing.
It's type thing though.
This is officer all when I say check
this out,
so here's,
here's the dress now a.
right?
So that's a,
that's not what I'm talking about,
but this shows a how it changes colors
if it goes into a shadow.
A what?
Yeah,
what I,
what I posted.
That is weird.
I do see that when you pull it back,
it goes into a shadow.
It changes color because your eyes are
to now going in,
you know,
it's the light.
Just change colors.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's fine.
Photographer Jamie explained to us and
absorb light reflects it,
and this is a,
it's like a yellow shitty lamp,
shitty camera and it's bouncing it off
and as soon as you move away from it,
the exposure changes,
the autofocus changes.
Wait,
Brian,
you went out and bought a dress.
Not a lot of things at play here and
people are just ignoring facts.
I think there's A.
There's trolls also playing into this
white and gold thing.
What are you talking about,
Jamie?
There's no talk.
Let them talk through it the whole time.
Like for instance,
uh,
the black and gold right there.
Watch it fading away.
I'm holding it like light is now on a
shit.
It's not a shadow.
By the way.
I don't know why you're showing this
video because I'm not even talking about
this.
Video has not been the same dress.
Hold on dude.
He's explaining what this effect is.
Let them talk.
This is my opinion.
I suppose I would say what is happening
here is I know this is a black and gold
dress,
or excuse me,
black and blue dress and what I'm seeing
it.
I'm just,
I'm going to go ahead and say,
yeah,
I know that there's also light here
affecting the way I'm seeing the black
and gold or black and blue dress and
it's making other people see gold and
they're just talking about him,
but let him explain.
Let me explain.
So why is that?
I think it's a difference with people
saying what they see and what they know.
They're seeing like an optical illusion.
Like remember the two faces make a vase
like ic two faces,
but someone else can see a vase.
It's just like,
what do you ever seen the blue and black
love?
Right?
I can see both of them and I also don't
think it matters.
This is a,
this is an optical illusion.
Here's,
here's what I'm talking about.
Here's proof that that we're seeing it
wrong.
Okay.
Go to this video where I opened it up in
photoshop and I invert the colors of the
screen.
When you invert a color to the opposite,
it should change right around instagram.
My twitter,
twitter.
Yeah.
It's fascinating,
man.
I.
It's hard for me to believe that that's
the same thing.
It's weird as it moves away,
what's confusing is that I understand
what moves away and absorbs light to
reflects light,
but what am I confused?
What is it when I see that one picture,
you see it differently.
If we change sides.
Jamie and the lighting was different.
What?
I see it the same way Joe sees it.
No,
because you're looking at an image,
so it's just our cones are shaped
differently,
so I pick up different amount of light
that you seen when that thing started
out.
Why don't you say I saw that too.
I see white and gold saw white gold too.
As it pulls away.
Do you still see what I see?
Blue,
blue and black enough as it pulls
closure as they do that again,
now I see what you're talking about when
you go to light blue and brown.
Hmm.
Like mustard.
Now I see.
This is a way more radical change than
the other one.
The other one,
that other image was like a kind of that
kind of.
It's like very light blue like you've.
We've always taken pictures before with
like weird lighting on a digital camera
and you're like,
oh,
was weird.
This doesn't look like,
but it really looked like in real life
because the colors are all off for
whatever reason,
something's too bright like a flash and
this is where I actually take this into
photoshop and I use this thing called a
color picker where it picks the color
and it shows you what the color is.
So what I was clicking on,
which looked to me immediately,
gold or yellow,
it was doing brown,
dark brown,
almost black,
and then when I did it to the,
the what I thought was white,
it was doing it to a blue.
So then I decided to reverse in all the
screens and the colors and watch how the
pictures six stay exactly the same.
I don't disagree with what you're saying
here,
but not all the data in there to
compress file.
It's not real life color,
but when you reverse colors it will
change color.
Right.
Well,
let's see.
Let's see what happens.
See what.
No,
it's the same colors.
What I'm saying,
it's white and gold right now.
That's goal kind of a golden white right
now.
No,
he totally blue and black.
You see right there,
right there,
right there.
Frozen screen,
dressed,
different type.
This is the problem.
That fucking weird.
Technically I.
Joe,
I think you know that it's black.
So you're saying it's black?
No,
no.
I'm seeing.
First of all,
the really important one,
the really important one is blue.
The blue's undeniable to me that the
other one that we're calling black
commitment to this class,
it's not gold.
It's way darker than gold,
but it's not black.
Have like space,
you know?
It's more like sort of like a dark,
dark bronze looking sort of a thing,
but it's not black or gold.
It's sort of disingenuous.
It's like a creepy,
but the only.
Yeah.
The only way it could be black
as if it's blocked.
It's like super overexposed,
but if you look at it in a more blurry
way,
somebody like if you,
if you like that image of behind you.
Here's what's interesting.
That image behind you on this different
television look behind you,
over your left shoulder that looks
different than that.
That looks way more black.
The one behind you on a totally
different television or different
lessons.
I seen a better tv that's got more
billions of more colors,
which it probably has.
The four K tv,
four K TV does.
This is the one that has the most,
has more resolution and might not have
more colors available.
Oh really?
Is that true?
Wow.
Four kids,
lines of resolution.
Whatever it is.
That one looks better.
That looks way better than that.
We'll see on both of them.
I see white and gold right now.
You see a completely different.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
When you're looking at these two
screens,
is one of them look clear to you more on
this one?
This one right here,
it looks brighter and crisper tray,
so it looks kind of more like dollar.
This looks like we're looking at the
same dress through fog.
Where this,
this podcast.
A factor that people that just listen,
stop it.
I don't want to stop it.
I don't want to stop it because it's
interesting because what you're saying I
think is important because you
understand it is from the point of view
of someone who understands like
perspective photography.
I've seen this happen multiple times.
The photos I've taken,
I can change through white balance.
I can change the way a whole photo looks
from green to Brown,
so you take a picture of either you can
make them blend like I see blue and
black that's done that outside,
smoke a cigarette.
I can't deal with this.
You're totally not totally not getting
the point.
Jamie.
I were both talking about contrast and
brightness.
How we can change and make things.
Look I'm saying is me and Joe are
looking at the exact same picture and it
looks exactly different.
Definitely a fact that seems to be going
on other than what you're talking about.
The thing when you're dealing with two
totally different issues.
First of all,
we're dealing with the change of color,
which was pretty drastic to me when I
watched it go from white to gold to blue
and black.
I was like,
wow,
this is really weird.
Like,
this is really weird,
but then we're dealing with a frozen
image and in that frozen image we see
different things to different things.
I think that blows me away a little bit.
Well,
that makes it yellow cars all of a
sudden make sense?
Now?
I was looking at yellow car.
I was like pitch.
Do you know there's a lot of other
colors.
What the fuck do you want a yellow
corvette?
This is ridiculous.
Mustard colored man now just like,
oh,
this one,
why not?
Black?
Black is like dope.
My heart pressure,
my blood pressure has gone up.
If you watch the video and brings it
down and it makes you still think that
time travel was created.
That day started off with Obama video.
It's just alumni getting away from
beliefs.
Cool as the leper.
It's a black one and a white one and
there's people like trying trick,
like walking next
to it like hey,
how's it going?
Hooked up.
And then the woman was like,
get the fuck away from immigrants.
Whether it's like police helicopters,
it's like news.
Just try not to kill it.
Right.
Captured.
I knew I do.
I'd Llamas Paul Barclay,
the owner of the comedy connection in
Boston,
one of the original owners.
He had a.
He also owned this club called the rack.
He's a very successful club owner club
called the rack member Brian.
We played at that place.
He was the pool hall that was right next
to the,
uh,
faneuil hall when we used to do the
common connection down there.
Anyway,
that dude own llamas.
He had a fucking giant spread out in the
Cape and he had fucking lamas on his
lawn and shit.
Yeah,
he wasn't.
The outback is the Alpac is what you
want.
And then you want one lama to be
dominant.
Exotic animals graze it on my fucking
yard.
That's like the ultimate to have some
crazy llamas in your front yard.
Do you smell?
What does that smell?
My fucking neighbors.
Llamas.
No,
I live on a farm.
Mama's been assaulted and raped that
they had.
That has not been the sole really driven
through it.
I've not stopped.
They have this lead a Llama farm where
you can just like hang out with a shit
logo.
Llamas Dude,
I entered,
I did an entire TV show about the
leaping Lama festival.
You want to know the best part of it is
the,
the crux of the competition is how much
you can adorn your Llama,
Llama with gear,
like put stuff on and cover its eyes and
how you can control it.
And you got to do a sketch in front of
the whole [inaudible] for all the
college high schools around all the
parents,
all the kids.
And I have no,
I'm not producing.
I'm just host.
And I go,
so what's it mean?
The llamas skit and they're like rocky
three.
I go,
oh,
it's my favorite rocky cover less than
rocky.
I go,
I'm rocky.
And they're like,
fuck yeah,
you're going to come out.
The music will be playing.
You get the Llama,
Llama is going to look just like mister
t.
So we get out.
I get it to the Llama was a white Lama.
They had to put it in black face,
like red lips.
And they were like,
let's part of the competition.
Is it pushing on his face?
I go,
it's black and gold.
To settle down,
you breaking glass all neighbor's wall.
It was and I had to dance out and they
play just some fucking eye of the tiger
and I didn't take bunches at this
fucking bike.
It's a fucking Lama.
Oh my God.
My friend Steve [inaudible] and his
brother Matt,
he's llamas.
When they hunt to carry out the meat,
what are the drug trained llamas trained
llamas.
They take them into like a cargo van.
They load them up in the back of the van
and they bring them to like Montana and
they pull them out of the van and these
things are hardy as fuck and they just.
They can just carry shit.
They don't give a fuck.
They don't get cold.
They just stand out there in the snow
and they're like whatever.
Like it doesn't bother them at all.
Their body temperature is way higher
than ours.
Their way sturdier than ours and they
use them.
The packout meat.
It's crazy.
He had a whole show about it and his
show about like these llamas going with
them out in.
They're like getting an elk and packing
into the back of these fucking llamas
and traveling out of the,
out of the woods with them.
It's just so weird.
He apparently he had a moose once and in
carrying the Moose back to his car,
like over and over again.
And all these trips he fucked his back
up so he literally couldn't hunt anymore
because he couldn't carry anything out
because he had hurt his back so bad.
So he trained.
All these moves are trained all these.
Um,
uh,
what other,
what are they called again?
Nice.
No,
the thing we were just talking about,
blah,
blah.
Most trained all these llamas to carry
out the world.
Lose weight.
No,
it's just that the word law,
I don't use that often.
It's not on the tip of my tongue.
I'll pocket was there for some reason.
I was like,
that's not it.
It's a Lama.
But.
So these fucking things are pissing
inside this van.
They'll let the skus thing back in.
It's cargo van and then they pull them
out and they slept in the van.
They'll spit at.
You just can't,
you know,
big cat,
Derek,
right?
Like,
I've been a Texas that has all the
animals.
He has a Llama in and uh,
he has these.
If you look at his,
uh,
videos on instagram,
big cat,
Derek,
he led his Lama in his house the other
day.
I don't know why he does this.
I think he just does it to film it,
but the loss is like breaking shit,
going through his tablets and throwing
things and it's just like polaris is his
great guy.
That's fucking rude.
Animal man was rude,
but they don't give a fuck dude.
They have these things in the mountains
in Montana.
It's snowing like crazy.
She was just standing there like they
don't give a fuck and it makes you
realize like we're so vulnerable when it
comes to the environment that we kind of
like think of all animals as even though
we know that other animals are more
harder than us,
we just don't understand like how could
they survive this environment?
But how did we.
Well,
we figured out a way.
Nobody.
I mean,
how did the first couple of generations.
It took awhile.
I'm sure we could only live in places
where you can live without any worry of
like heat heating yourself.
Like that was the big issue.
Like everything started out in the rain
forest,
right?
That's what they think.
It all started out in Africa.
If it all started out in Africa,
Africa is warm as fuck.
Okay.
The last thing you have to worry about
as close,
the last thing you have to worry about
is the abundance of life.
The first thing you have to worry about
is not becoming food.
That's number one.
So it's all about getting to the high
trees have figured out weapons and it
starts out.
You're a bunch of super horny monkeys
who fucked like crazy because had to
reproduce as much as you can and
everybody fucks everybody so that nobody
gets greedy as far as like a loser
motherfucker.
Kids,
your kids can suck my dick.
Everybody's like raising everybody
because you're just trying to keep away
from Jaguars and fucking leopards and
shit and whatever the hell else is
trying to eat you.
So that's what we were forever until we
slowly but surely figured out weapons,
figured out,
weapons and shelter.
As soon as we get think we could fuck it
up,
build something from nothing,
get in and go,
okay,
how do you want to deal with this
motherfuckers dude,
I've been thinking,
you know,
like you pull a stick and it kinda like
goes back to the original shape.
If I tie him fucking string on that
bench and then have some shit with like
a long pointy thing that's sharpen the
end,
I think he can fly I think on my
shooting right at these fucking crazy
bear that are eating our babies and
we're going to figure out how to
dominate these woods.
And then next thing you know,
they started killing things and they
started using fire.
They figured out how to knock rocks
together to create sparks in the embers
would blow on it like dried moss and
shit that they had saved for this
occasion.
They get that little amber crackling and
they stack would upon it and that keeps
the animals away from the animals.
Can't believe they can control the fire.
These motherfuckers that fire in their
hands and they slowly figured out how to
stockpile food.
They slowly figured out how to make
walls of community.
Like I think like at times like nine 11
community becomes tighter because
there's fear.
Fear is out there.
Do you think when people were getting
eaten and they were a community,
do you think community was tighter or do
you think there are people that talk
shit behind people's backs?
They think the gossipy shit,
like really like gossipy type,
like the way people do it today and the
way people like,
especially into celebrity gossip.
There's one theory that I found really
fascinating was that they think that it
has something to do with a lack of
community.
Like someone was talking about.
They were talking about communities
bonding together against an enemy like
which is what cities used to be like.
Cities used to bond together.
They used to have to worry about someone
from outside coming into their meds,
but now people don't do that anymore
because they don't really know their
neighbors,
so they're not bonded with all the
people that they live next to the,
that they live next to her almost
inconvenient and instead of it being
like the best people in the world,
like they're all like,
everyone's surrounded together.
No,
you just next to Mr.
Johnson and he's kind of an asshole and
his dog shits on your yard and it's
fuck,
you know,
there's always like,
there's always some weirdness involved,
but if there were lions roaming through
the community,
we'd all be a lot tighter.
Yeah.
If you had to,
if you had to use a title,
a great idea for a community service
project,
just released the line one line,
no,
probably just going to be somebody who
doesn't realize that lying can fucking
kill you and they'll be really mad if
you kill the lion.
You know,
this is people that like they,
they really do choose animals over
people and animals.
Welfare over people.
Like what we were saying before about
people working hard to keep the Tigers
alive.
Like I get it.
I believe me.
I got it.
I'm completely joking.
I don't want tigers to go extinct,
but if I lived in India I would be like,
fuck in Rambo.
Okay.
I would make an iron man and I'd get
every fucking wet with tigers.
Ain't my family dude.
I would go when guns.
Yeah.
I would just be wandering through.
The tall grass is gunning down those
cunty cats.
Imagine v Eight,
your mom in front of you.
Tiger eight.
Your fucking mother.
And dragged her off the top of a tree.
Like what?
What?
What is this world where you're trying
to save these things that I'm not
fucking metal helmet on.
Like iron man and shit.
All fucking bolted down.
Just a giant carbon fiber and metal
outfit with machine guns,
with like a brilliant writer to watch
him a backpack filled with ammo.
Wow.
I just fuck tigers.
I was 10 feet from a lion about a month
ago.
10 feet from ally in the wild.
Just watch it does little.
Just every little movement of an animal
is so heightened when it could kill you
because it looks at you.
One of those be those supporters.
Yeah.
Why don't you open air?
Why are they open like that?
Because it's a real.
It's a real like you.
And it's scary.
I'd look,
I'd love to be in a van,
but it's real because you see the will
to beach running next to you and you're
running right next to them and then you
see the line and you see the hippo.
Usually the giraffe.
You see everything out there.
You don't see gorillas.
That's not,
that's the wrong place.
But like,
uh,
the line was 10 feet from us.
I mean,
uh,
for me to that wall right there.
And I just looked at it and it looks at
you,
just like a cat just looks at you,
flaps its tail tail stares and looks off
and used to waiting for it to make that
one move.
Like,
Huh.
And then go.
It's all fucking over.
But it was,
it was well worth.
It is amazing that timelines for an
episode to Herbert one time here.
What'd you have to do?
Going around going to a room,
a cage with like for I guess
theoretically unruly lions,
boom.
Three to four lions and they call them
out and they gave me a two.
I.
They gave me like a to fanny,
fanny pack full of Sirloin plunger.
Stick with a nail on it and I liked.
This is called your meat stick.
Don't lose it.
Don't drop it.
They respect you.
As long as you have your meat stick,
put meat on the meat stick and the lions
will respond to the meat.
Fuck.
Smell of fear coming off.
You must have been like a like a New
Jersey fucking trash dump.
It must've been just wall.
This guy is terrified.
It was fucking really scary.
Smell that.
Do you think they get swole?
Dude?
Oh,
when you see that animal size you up,
there's no doubt that is the king of the
jungle.
I'm.
I'm being dead serious.
He called out.
It's a little bit of it sounds.
It's gonna.
I'm not going to do the bidding part of
it.
What sounds like a bit,
but like it's very true.
He calls him out.
He said they all listened to the,
to,
to the head of the pride,
cost them out and he's like,
move Fossa and this just comes out.
When you see a lion look at you.
It's not,
it's not like another,
it's not like someone walking.
It's like someone walking by you in
prison.
He sizes you up.
I mean I looked at that thing and he,
his eyes are huge.
His lungs,
as you breathe,
feel like golf bags were being squeezed.
I mean you could hear these brands like,
I mean,
and it just runs up and then it stands
there,
but it never keeps a take.
Texas I off you.
It's never like know what the fuck's
going on.
It's just staring at you,
sizing you up.
He caught up to more lions.
The next one's name was a Simba and the
last one's name was like dog or Reggie,
like it was fucking horrible,
but the,
he calls it over and it just.
The one last one was truly and just went
right up to me,
a nose in my junk but not but powerful.
You know,
when a dog does it and everyone's like,
oh,
and they hold their but doesn't feel
like he's in it.
He put his nose,
my junk and bent me over,
like,
and I dropped the meat stick and I'm
fumbling for my fucking meat.
I'm like,
it was,
it was intense as fuck.
Oh my God.
We did this thing called the ring of
circle or the tunnel of death where they
stand the lines up for lions and they
hang over and they,
and they grow with you as you walk
through the door.
Just just like your fucking night.
Now it's your first night in prison,
mother fucker.
And it was broader.
It was fucking insane.
Uh,
for TB.
So that no one saw that.
The scariest thing you've ever had to
do.
I've done who I.
The scariest thing was getting mauled by
the bull probably because I really got
hurt and I could've gotten killed.
That's probably the scariest thing.
You know,
you've seen it hit type in Herbert Rodeo
clown.
Oh,
that's,
yeah.
I'm sure we have.
That was probably the scariest guy
realized,
oh fuck.
There is no,
there is no like into like a golden egg
policy in this TV show.
They don't really give a fuck if I get
hurt.
My ribs broke my foot and I was like,
and then I remember getting done and
they were like,
ah,
we need more footage.
This is just me getting bolt.
This is perfect.
So this bull,
this is a big fucking bull dude.
Oh my stuck in a bullpen with this.
Thank God my foot's broken.
I'm trying to run on it,
but it's broken.
Oh my God.
Charged you to death.
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.
That's,
that's when I realized that's what
scared me the most about a reality
driven hosts.
Reality shows and they needed me that we
had actually shot for about another hour
of me in a,
in a,
in a barrel and it will hit in the
barrel because.
Because this is back when you had to
make tv that was eight minutes,
like get an a,
do an eight minute cigarette for five
minute segment.
So it didn't feel like they had it just
a shot.
What kind of fucking producers do you
have?
Man,
that's ridiculous.
The same one that maybe I told the
fighting the bear story on,
this isn't happening.
This is not happening.
It's the same producer.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
Was like reckless with you.
He made me wear makeup.
I was uh,
yeah.
That,
that was probably the scariest thing
I've done to date.
Having said that,
obviously jumping on a plane and Rachel
Ray was terrifying.
Uh,
being the first guy to jump off the
stratosphere is pretty insane.
A lot of these rope swings when I'm
doing these days,
I showed you the one in Durbin,
but we didn't want in Switzerland.
That was like fucking next level.
Terrifying.
Fucking horrifying.
When I began investing big animals,
you can't tell them to like take it a
50% so that we get the shot.
What did that feel like when that thing
fucking slammed into you?
Helpless.
It's like he ever been in a car accident
and you and you went,
oh fuck,
I forgot.
Um,
for this fragile,
helpless.
When it hit me,
I remember,
I remember it instantly knocking the
hell out of me.
Oh.
And um,
but there was this,
this,
uh,
this fight or flight fight or flight
survival instinct where I was and my
foot was broken and my ribs were broken
an automatic.
I just get up,
like I remember the first words,
I said,
how do we get out of here?
But it's not like there's no TV in my
head.
I'm just like,
how the fuck do I get out of here?
And they told me the number one thing
they said do not go to the walls of the
ring because he pinned you in between
there,
he won't let go and,
and that'll kill you.
And I went by,
I didn't,
I didn't think I just went right to the
fucking wall to get out of there because
I was like,
I'm in the middle of the fucking pen,
it's going to come back for me.
It's going to stop me.
He says Christ.
And they had no fucking plan to keep you
safe.
They had no plan,
no plan.
And I think,
I think fx canceled that knowing,
fuck,
we really dodged a bullet.
This kid could have been killed.
Um,
but,
uh,
trust issues,
now I have a hard.
Especially.
No,
I know that sounds like joke.
I have a hardcore trust issues with
reality shows should a very,
like I,
everyone that works on [inaudible]
conquer,
they all know that I,
I'm like,
I feel like you may fuck with my safety
to get the shot.
And here's the other problem is
sometimes when I say this,
and I know maybe you've listened to this
and you've been a part of this,
but there are guys that know me.
If they see me on an we're shooting and
they recognize this podcast,
you know,
my honesty,
the problem sometimes is going to a
place where you go,
like,
uh,
we're going to go redneck button and uh,
and we've got a guy,
we got a truck,
we're going to interview on TV,
then we're going to get his truck and
he's going to take us for a ride.
Well sometimes it's not always,
you know,
across the board that you can't drink in
those trucks.
And a lot of times the guys are
drinking.
And the other thing that is kind of
fucked up is,
is what I want to paint it off,
that all these red mud things are,
but often they don't really care.
And the other thing is,
is that for TV,
that one guy who has been drinking,
whose names like Bubba,
he wants to.
You got to show the Hollywood boy what
we do down here in Alabama.
And I'm going to say in Alabama was the
place that we did this.
I understand what you're saying.
We gotta we gotta show this Hollywood
boy had.
Hey Ricky,
bobby Bubba,
take until the next level.
Oh Shit.
And you get guys were,
were they say to you stuff like,
you're going to get fucked up tonight,
Hollywood.
And you're like,
and you just,
it's this weird thing you do.
You do.
Do a fucking sky jumps in these jumps.
And they're like.
So the guy was telling me I did want to
Switzerland,
he goes,
make sure you lift your feet.
You might hit the rock.
And I went,
hold on.
I go,
I need to know if I'm gonna.
Hit The fucking rock.
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking with you because you're
making a TV show and they think they're
happy.
I'll be making better TV shows.
And,
and so that happens a lot of times as
you'd go to these fucking tracks.
Are these,
these like,
you know,
like we were enough top fuel dragster,
a hundred 1,530
miles an hour in three seconds and uh,
and I had a panic full panic attack like
because they put you in a flame
retardant suit,
five point harness the harness your
hands,
so the suit,
so you can't move your hands.
So now.
So you're basically in handcuffs and
like a straight jacket,
they put a helmet on you in a neck brace
on the helmet around you.
So in a titan helmet up and you cannot
move.
It's for your safety.
But I started panicking and I was like
very clear.
I was like,
hey guys,
I don't need you to try to break the
world record like 130 miles an hour in
three seconds it's going to look pretty
fast and you just want to make sure that
they don't want to make the thing that
they're making the show better.
Danger.
Yeah,
that sounds really fucking dangerous.
There's a lot of things,
but it's all.
It's all.
I mean,
you know,
everything was that we've ever done has
always been engaged in safety,
but that's because I'm an executive
producer and I'm,
fuck everyone knows what pussy,
but isn't it fascinating,
dude,
that you have these like really
contradictory feelings,
like you're terrified of shifts here job
like a big part of your job entails you
putting yourself in tremendous danger
for no reason whatsoever.
Think about that all the time.
I wonder.
I wonder what the Fuck's wrong with me?
I'm trying to exercise it out of your
system or something.
Here's the thing.
So like I went scuba diving at 80 feet.
Go wreck.
I had a panic attack halfway through the
swim back up,
Lord,
in a moment of panic,
in a real panic.
It's beautiful because it's never.
Life's never been more defined in what
you want and what you don't want.
I want nothing at the bottom of the
ocean.
All the Shit I dig this up top.
But I ended up doing it and seeing the
[inaudible] feet,
my brain the whole time.
It was like,
I could totally fuck with you right now.
And uh,
and celebrating it.
I mean,
it's,
it's finding new boundaries in your
spirit or your soul or your DNA and
getting the next level.
And I dictated to it.
Here's your space.
Traveling.
Everybody wants to go to space.
You know,
what's up there rocks?
How are you going to the ocean?
Fucking sharks,
clams and crabs and eels and weird
fucking things that have fishing rods
grown out of their heads,
trick and fish and opening their mouth
up like some cartoon,
Monster Fish in space with monsters that
world's way.
Crazier spaces,
stupid spaces.
We've been waiting those flat every
night.
No flying saucers.
That's just infinity.
Go that ocean.
That's how.
That's the fucking the wildest world out
there,
man.
That's so true that they said there were
monsters like just the just 20,000
a few
killer whales in the clouds.
How fucking popular.
See where it would be.
Killer whales,
mccloud's.
Blame your own playing like that would
be fucking amazing.
Could you imagine if you had to go to
space to see like con doors.
You get up there and you'd see that
fucking bird and they wanted to hit on.
You only exist in space.
You'd have to go see him in space.
You would appreciate them way more.
Way more than birds down here.
Whereas down here,
bullshit.
Give a fuck.
If you see a duck will not pulling the
car over for ducks.
Ducks in space.
They are the craziest things ever.
If were on the moon,
they were like,
get the fuck here.
This on the goddamn ducks at the park.
We can go feed them.
They wait for people to throw bread.
Adam,
who gives a fuck if they're in space.
It's like something in spaces.
Makes it way cooler.
If you found some naked retard on the
moon,
you'd be like,
there's a Guy lemme get retarded though.
You're like,
oh,
it's from bucket space.
He slept there.
Welcome to the moon quiz.
He's probably jerking off at the camera.
We find intelligent life.
I use sure.
You got a guy who's beaten off on the
moon camera.
We were so excited.
We found that he is trying to
communicate.
We're trying to give him the benefit of
the doubt because all the years of
loneliness and madness alone,
beating off on the moon.
He didn't understand how inappropriate
it was and our culture.
We cannot expect him,
the crazy man on the moon to have our,
our ethics and our look at the world.
That guy would be so many miles.
It's just there's a million of those
guys in insane asylums all across the
country.
We're not.
We don't appreciate them.
You're in there.
Then that room got a cage.
Not that big a deal,
but if that guy is jerking off and the
nurses face on the moon,
it was just him and the nurse on the
moon and then you see him.
He's holding her down,
jerking off in her face,
like,
what the fuck is going on?
On the moon?
Insane asylum on the moon.
It sounds like a movie should be.
Should it be rob Zombie's next film.
Ah.
Why did you a so much about joe?
He doesn't dream because you said you
said two separate occasions.
Shit,
when I'm not around.
And then tell me a distorted version is
you're a old cat still alive.
Josef.
I'm,
I think this might be the,
the week it's a day by day.
I'm like,
you know,
I'm going to let you live one more day.
You know,
it's just getting too bad.
She's too old in a micro school.
Right.
She can't see good anymore.
She's 19 now.
He.
Yeah.
So she,
um,
she can still hop up on the couch and
she still does.
She fall down like my shit falling a
lot.
Yeah,
she falls.
We used to have her food,
like it was like on this little counter
area.
She would jump up to it,
but now she's slipped a couple times and
sad,
sad to watch her slip.
When is it the point where you're like,
all right,
when she's on pain and pain,
how do we know we're not pain?
I don't know.
She might be,
but when I feel like she's miserable,
you know,
I don't want her to just slowly die.
If you could put her asleep,
it's probably more humane.
I was.
I've been like looking at her and she
sleeps about 99% of her life now in
about the same age,
about 17,
something like that.
Uh,
but,
but when,
uh,
when she does it a way in which he is
awake,
she's puking a,
she can barely pay in the litter box
anymore,
you know,
she's just going right outside of it or
something like that.
And uh,
it's just like if she,
she in pain,
they get dementia.
Yeah.
The little a kitty,
cat,
Alzheimer's,
you know,
they,
they meow in the middle of the night.
So how.
Yeah,
that's really bad now.
Yeah.
My cat,
she picks up my daughter's shoes,
like my daughter has like these uggs
soft shoe.
She picks him up and carries them in her
mouth and while she's carrying them in
her mouth,
she's going,
it's weird politics.
It's a kitten.
I don't know what she.
She never had kittens.
You know what I mean?
Maybe she's going mad because she never
had babies.
And here's a question for you.
When this happens,
do you.
I've never had to deal with this arc.
I didn't even think of that.
Do you?
Do you,
do you have to go to shoot or you go to
the vet,
whoever put asleep a war,
do you think it's cooler to like just go
to like a nice field and just let her
just be like,
look,
you know,
good luck Brian.
No,
Brian,
why would you say that?
Because it's so she's going to starve to
death.
I feel like it's like I'm getting my
like it's either going,
hey,
I remembered gift.
Chill.
You're going to go onto the chair,
like you're going to go into electric
chair or we're leaving the door open.
Prison doors though my shot,
they give him a shot,
but within moments of electric they
give.
The cat is shot and they're dead within
moments where they do the ivy and
they're dead.
Within moments you do.
Here's what you do.
Schedule an appointment to put her down
tomorrow.
She'll start acting 100%.
As soon as you schedule that appointment
anytime.
Anytime you have to put it on an animal
today you go,
alright.
Here it goes there.
Totally perfect.
Like,
well she's probably,
my cat is probably a little healthier
than yours because she still gets around
and you know,
she sleeps a lot,
but she comes over to me and she wants
to get pet,
but she sounds like she's like,
oh,
voice sounds Kathy.
Susan sound happy.
It's like a squawk.
You know,
she's 19 years old,
man for cats.
That's a long ass time.
I can't live with me and the other side
of the world.
Is there like some stupid law that you
have to hold your cat when they put put
it to sleep?
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
you do?
Okay,
cool.
Can you just.
Yeah,
that's called love of having a heart.
No,
it wasn't.
You can't just like hand it in a box,
but I'm done with it.
Yeah.
Well,
you're going to want,
trust me.
You're going to want to be there.
You pay extra for that or for them to
come to your house and do it.
I was there for a puppy that had this
temporary,
uh,
we got it from this guy,
um,
I can kinda from callan was callan's
friend and um,
it had distemper and it started having
seizures.
It was awful.
And then there's like this not in the
seizures kept coming more and more
frequent and his dog would just lock up
the agony and the doctor was like,
you know,
there's really no hope at this stage.
And I'm like,
oh,
I can't believe this.
Like the moment we got him,
he's really cute too.
And uh,
that was,
it was hard man,
because the doctor was crying.
I'm like,
yeah,
we held the,
held onto the puppy.
He gives the puppy this shot and it just
goes stiff.
I was there through the whole thing.
Go stiff,
man.
It's just,
uh,
I mean just went limp rather,
you know.
And um,
yeah,
it's hard to watch man.
And the,
I'm the guy who's like,
I've talked about him before.
His name is Dr.
Craig.
He was cool,
like a really cool guy.
He died,
were killed by a drunk driver man.
Somebody slammed into him one day I got
an email or something about it might
have been an actual physical mail
because it was quite awhile ago and I
was so bummed out because they cared
about animals so much.
He had been around so many animals that
had to get put to sleep.
But when that puppy died and I was
crying,
he started crying too.
Man,
he's a doctor,
you know,
it's like,
it's the hardest part of my job because
I love being able to say.
But he had like fucking 15 dogs,
like the guy who loved animals hit a
bunch of cats,
a bunch of dogs,
you know,
who's just a sweetheart of a guy man.
Sad shit tonight.
Everybody take it easy on the podcast.
Yeah,
we've been fighting that with Chris or
my dog at home too.
But she's had five knee surgeries.
My God,
five.
Now we're getting the big one,
the knee replacement.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
What's wrong with her?
Why is she purebred purebred into
overbred interbreeding and she had a
torn acl and acl.
I,
sweet dog like that.
She had both are acl replaced.
She's had both.
Are acl done twice and she's had her
knees kneecaps put back in place.
Degenerative Degenerative kneecaps and
now and the one leg,
her right leg just never really healed.
So we went in and we went to therapy and
they're like,
look,
uh,
there is no cartilage in there.
The only thing was possible was the knee
replacement or we cut the leg off or we
just leave it as she drags it.
And uh,
and I was just in the place where I was
like,
I was like,
I'm ready to pay so much fucking money
for this dog.
Get the fucking new knee.
Did you talk to a knee replacement?
They think there's any light on the
horizon.
80%,
80% chance that it's going to be fine.
I think they put that out of all the
cases of knee replacements,
but it's only been around for a couple
of years,
so they're getting better at it
obviously,
but just to be able to give this dog and
opportunity to run and chase play and
just play other than sit on the couch
and like,
you know,
come up and get.
I mean it gets love
all the time,
but.
So yeah,
I've seen those ones that doing for
people now,
they showed there was an animated
version of the operation online or doing
a full knee replacement.
It's fucking crazy.
You're watching just going like,
what's crazy?
Soften your knee off and putting this
new piece,
a new piece of equipment that's like on
a,
you know,
a groove and socket sorta set up and
you're watching this whole thing that
screws into place and like,
what the fuck man?
We're making bionic knees.
Yeah.
But I guess for people that have it,
man,
it's a huge pain relief for people that
are like,
some people have degenerative diseases
of their joints and it just gets to the
point where there's nothing they could
do about it.
They're just like rouse,
like,
you know Sean Rouse.
I did.
I just hit them up this week.
I want to.
I love.
He's so funny.
He's hilarious.
He's such a talented comedian.
Very,
very funny dude.
And he has a very extreme case of
arthritis,
whereas I guess it's called a rheumatoid
but very extreme.
Whereas his hands and his knees and like
he's always an agony.
And I,
I know he's had some,
I think he's had some,
he just got new knees or something like
that.
So I believe Russell Peters bottle
before.
Wow.
That sounds like Russell Russell's spine
knees to go by.
My dog's name will rouse really funny
fucking comic man.
Really Fun.
Really talented.
A fucking beyond talented comic.
Yeah,
it's,
it's sad when you see shit like that and
you just don't know what,
what is it?
I mean,
could they fix it?
Well,
what's the solution like?
There's gotta be a way to improve that,
that that's,
that's the beautiful thing about medical
science is that they look at a situation
like that and they slowly but surely
chip away at all the different ways to
fix the problem.
Like every day they're coming up with
all these new methods for dealing with
things that were almost insurmountable
just a little while ago.
Like they got this doctor in Germany
that's replacing people's discs now.
I've heard of quite a few people going
there and I talked to a doctor about it
and he explained to me that there are
certain,
um,
artificial discs that they've created in
Germany that,
you know,
for people that have neck injuries or
back injuries,
a lot of times they get their discs
fused.
And what that means is they take your
two bones of your desk,
they remove all the,
the jail that separate.
So they cut it all away and they put the
two bones together and they screw them
into each other.
So now you only have the degeneration of
the disc above it and the disc below it,
you have one giant fat disks.
It doesn't move that well,
so you just can't go like all the way
back,
fucks with your movement.
It fucks with your mobility for some
people.
But for some people that's a significant
like release of pain.
And so then they came out with these
spacers.
They had these space.
Are they used in replacement of a desk?
I believe that that's what the,
the operation they did that Tito Ortiz
and they explained it on the UFC.
They showed like the doctor came and
showed this space or this plastic
spacer.
But what they figured out now in Germany
is like this articulating sort of moving
joint almost.
And they're putting in people's necks.
I know Braulio esteem got one of those,
uh,
I don't know if the same thing,
but he's a world famous Jujitsu champion
who had a significant neck injury.
He had his disc replacement,
artificial disc and talked about it and
how much of a benefit it was to him.
So these guys are getting these discs
like where they were like really fucked
up before.
And uh,
this one guy's a skier and he was fucked
up before and he's had like two or three
discs replaced with these artificial
disc and now he's like skiing again.
It feels great and I'm like,
that's crazy.
Like they're putting like robot disks in
people.
Oh,
I love,
I have a bad neck problems and shoulder
problems.
What's your issues?
I have no fucking clue.
I have no idea.
Oh,
nothing.
Just 150 miles an hour under the side of
a mountain in Vegas I think.
Yeah,
I think that might have something to do
with it.
Fuck there.
I get it goes from my elbow to my.
I told you about that.
I was worried I was going to deal with
what Bas rutten's dylan with.
Yeah.
But he gets it from Emma and I got on it
actually
bus route and had like a few neck
problems from Emma and from Jiu Jitsu
kickboxing.
But the big one happened to him during
stunt work.
He was doing an episode of sons of
anarchy and he got dropped on his head
and it fucked his neck up like that.
That like really fucked up and that's
when he had to get his dis fused and all
that jazz.
So it wasn't even like Emma.
It was like doing stunt work style Orvis
hard fucking work,
man.
Those guys at ride those bowls all the
time.
Those guys,
I mean people that are at Rodeo clowns
like there's some hard workout there.
Oh yeah.
Dude.
You just in the same category.
You know,
there are a lot of men that are out
there that are just fearless.
I could never.
I mean I guess I do do it a little bit,
but to.
I've seen stuntmen do ridiculous shit
and movies.
You watch some of those making of movies
when you see like car accidents.
He stopped going to have to do our
motorcycle wrecks,
have to lay down bikes and I'm like,
she needs to Christ all for some shitty
mood.
Laydown bikes is the scary ones.
You don't know what's gonna happen with
it.
Like we've done,
we've done spin outs in cars where we've
had cars come and hit us and spin us
out.
But ultimately,
you know,
it's not gonna flip laying down a bike.
I saw one in anchorman the other day,
jacked by black,
supposed to do it,
but the bike fucking caught and started
flipping crazy.
Do I bet that was one fucking stuck and
lost his shit.
Yeah.
If he didn't lose his shit,
he's a better man than I am.
Somebody dying at Steven Seagal movie
was making a Steven Seagal movie died
some sort of a wreck.
Like imagine if he'd died for one of
those trade shows.
The end ones that not like the early
ones either.
It's not like above the law,
but the law was bad ass.
To this day I still enjoy blah,
blah blah.
That comes on fun.
Stupid movie.
The one where he's the.
He's the cook in the navy.
No,
that was definitely a good one.
That's a good one here in a few good
ones,
but ship one that was
a good one under to understand is pretty
good.
This ship one?
Yeah.
My Buddy Mike Star was on one of those
with them and he had to do a fight scene
with steven seagal where like the chest
protector,
let's Scott Punch them in the chest.
He said socked,
you know,
it wasn't,
just regular actor to.
It wasn't even a stunt guy,
but you're getting your chest lit up by
some guys.
Big fucker.
Who knows how to punch you.
Excuse me.
He's big.
He's a big fucker.
He's a big dude.
He's probably like six,
four,
six,
three,
somewhere in there.
Oh Wow.
How tall guess take a guess.
I'm gonna.
Say I was gonna I was gonna.
Say Five.
10.
No,
he's.
How tall is Steven Seagal series six for
found on the web for how tall is
Steven's ago?
Yeah.
See it's not automatically and that's
enough.
I'm his sister.
Katie Sagal wasn't married with
children.
Oh really?
That's his sister.
The mom from married with children.
You 100%.
Nailed it.
Why does it?
He's an openstack thing.
I'm looking at you and sister Jamie.
Jamie.
You're just a white dress.
Gold looking motherfucker today.
Aren't you going to stick to this?
I bet.
I bet jamie proved to be correct.
D then
I'm on burnside.
Steven,
how you believe that their son is Jason
Segel.
What does it say?
Relatives.
Jeans.
Here we go.
She changed her.
Is that her name?
White Gold.
That's her
not.
No,
she.
This is keeping Steven off there because
she's embarrassed.
She felt totally different.
Now Steven Seagal and gall or fucking
brother's sister.
Play through some data.
So a Steven Seagal is website.
She's not proud of it.
The way a trucking the grocery products.
Steven Seagal made of a bunch of shit
about being a navy seal.
Why wouldn't he make up a bunch of shit
about this?
Didn't he?
Didn't even do some like special ops
world.
I think you're do.
Doing Great.
Brian Williams,
Quito,
Hollywood.
Legitimate Martial art here.
I'm reading right here.
Steven Seagal.
Younger brother too.
The more famous Katey Sagal.
Come on.
Was that on fucking Bob's website?
Fuck what it was.
Noon.
Hold on.
The guy's legit martial artists.
Hey look,
maybe they're not brother and sister.
You fuck son of a bitch.
You son of a bitch.
Just ruin the story in my head because
I'm not hearing you so much more are not
relay.
You survive.
It's spelled the same.
It's ruined it for me though.
Fuck you guys.
I always had an interesting story.
I've been growing together or your view
of reality is quite rigid.
Look,
Steven Seagal is a fine gentleman and
excellent martial artists case ago.
A fine actor in her own right.
You have their name with you.
Horrible.
You were so committed to that rumor.
I want to know the truth.
I haven't had been holding that in my
head for fucking years and being like
the fascinating that they both kind of
took different angles in the business.
They don't even look like what would
have taken was a simple google search.
You just weren't willing to do it,
but you were willing to get on this
podcast,
argue to the fucking death.
I believe in faith.
You got to have faith.
I heard from George Michael's and Fred
durst.
Alright,
that's it.
Podcast.
Over good night everybody.
Bert Kreischer.
Follow him on twitter at Brian redband.
Red [inaudible] on twitter.
A.
Be back later this week.
See A.
Yeah,
we do ice house Friday.
No,
I can't.
Do you want to do comedy store next
Wednesday?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm here.
We're still going through.